I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello everyone. Welcome to Office Lady 6.0. Hello everyone. Welcome to Office Lady 6.0.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多VFF的故事，带你深入了解《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妹6.0。大家好。欢迎来到办公室辣妹6.0。大家好。欢迎来到办公室辣妹6.0。
Today we are going back to the very beginning of the world of the office. And we have a special guest to help us travel back in time. Angela, that is such a poetic way to describe this episode. I'm sorry, I got here early. I had a lot of free time on my hands. Maybe I overthought that one.
今天我们将回到“办公室”世界的最初起点。我们有一位特别嘉宾来帮助我们进行时间旅行。安吉拉，你对这一集的描述真是太诗意了。对不起，我来早了。我有很多空闲时间。也许我把那句话想得太复杂了。
You know, I don't know what got into me. I love an origin story. What can I say? Well, it is true that today we are starting at the beginning. We have rewatched the BBC pilot of The Office. And as it turns out, I have a connection to someone from the BBC office, and they're joining us today. You do. Tell them who it is, lady.
你知道，我不知道自己是怎么了。我就是喜欢起源故事。我能说什么呢？好吧，确实今天我们要从头开始。我们重温了英版《办公室》的试播集。结果证明，我和英版办公室的一位工作人员有渊源，他们今天会加入我们。你真的认识。告诉大家是谁吧，女士。
My lady friend just texted Lucy Davis because they're pals. Lucy plays Dawn Tinsley in the BBC The Office. She's joining us in the studio today to give us all the behind the scenes details of how the show began. Well, you know Lucy from The Office and she was also in Shaun of the Dead, Wonder Woman,
我的好朋友刚刚给露西·戴维斯发了信息，因为她们是好朋友。露西在英版《办公室》中饰演唐·坦斯利。她今天将来到我们的演播室，为我们揭秘节目开始的所有幕后细节。嗯，大家通过《办公室》认识了露西，她还演过《僵尸肖恩》、《神奇女侠》、
and Chilling Adventures of Sabrina. She's just the loveliest person and very, very funny. We are so excited to have her here with us. Lady, she is the original Office Lady. She is. So I think we should just jump right in. Here we go. Hello, everyone.
以及《萨布丽娜的惊心冒险》。她真的是最可爱的人，而且非常非常有趣。我们很高兴她能来到这里。女士，她才是初代办公室辣妹。确实如此。所以我觉得我们应该直接开始。我们开始吧。大家好。
We have such a fun guest here today. Lucy! Hello. It is Lucy Davis, you guys. Dawn Tinsley from the original office. The UK version of the office. Why we ever had jobs in the first place. Oh, I'm glad this is down to me.
我们今天请到了一位非常有趣的嘉宾。露西！你好。大家快看，是露西·戴维斯。原版办公室里的唐·坦斯利。英国版的办公室。我们当初怎么会有工作的。哦，很高兴这事落在我头上。
Okay, good, good. Thank you. We can leave Ricky and Steve way out of this. Oh, I'm glad this is down to me. Okay, good, good. We can leave Ricky and Steve way out of this. Well, they're not here today. They're not here, so there we are. The show is mine. That's right, that's right. You know, we're so excited to have you on today.
好吧，很好，很好。谢谢。我们可以把里奇和史蒂夫完全排除在外。哦，很高兴这事落在我头上。好吧，很好，很好。我们可以把里奇和史蒂夫完全排除在外。好吧，他们今天不在这里。他们不在这里，所以就这样吧。这个节目是我的了。没错，没错。你知道的，我们今天很高兴你能来。
We're gonna break down the pilot episode of the BBC's The Office. You're gonna take us through it. We're gonna ask you questions. It's The Office. You're going to take us through it. We're going to ask you questions. It's pretty cool. But, you know, we always like to kick things off by asking people, how did you get your job on The Office? Ooh, I tell you, it was 1999,
我们要剖析BBC版《办公室》的试播集。你将带我们一起回顾。我们要向你提问。这就是《办公室》。你将带我们一起回顾。我们要向你提问。这真是太酷了。但是，你知道，我们总是喜欢通过问别人这个问题来开始：你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？噢，我跟你说，那是1999年，
and it was just, everyone was breaking up for Christmas. And I had auditioned for a bunch of comedy pilots, none of which I had particularly gelled with. It was still in a time when those, you know, live audience comedies were very, very broad and nothing against that. I just didn't fit easily into that. And so I went in and I auditioned,
当时每个人都在准备过圣诞节放假。我去试镜了一堆喜剧试播集，没有一个是我特别有感觉的。当时那种有现场观众的喜剧非常非常大众化，我并不是针对这个。我只是很难融入其中。于是我去了，并进行了试镜，
Ricky Gervais wasn't there then. And I auditioned, then I got a call back and then Ricky was there and Steve Merchant. We were in a tiny room with an extremely large table. So you had to kind of shimmy your way around it. And I did a scene, which stayed in the pilot, where Dawn gets fake fired. That's what I auditioned with. That's what I auditioned with.
里奇·热维斯当时不在。我试镜了，然后我得到了回调通知，当时里奇和史蒂夫·麦道夫都在。我们在一个极小的房间里，里面有一张非常大的桌子。所以你必须侧着身子绕过它。我演了一场最终保留在试播集里的戏，就是唐被假解雇的那场。这就是我试镜时演的。这就是我试镜时演的。
Oh my, okay. But that was so funny, that was our audition scene. Yeah. That was our audition scene. Yeah. That's mad. Yeah. And originally, I don't know what was in yours, but in ours, originally, when Dawn then is crying and breaking down, Ricky tries to explain it's a joke, she says something to him and walks out the room,
天哪，好吧。但那太搞笑了，那是我们的试镜戏。是的。那是我们的试镜戏。是的。太疯狂了。是的。原本——我不知道你们的是什么样的，但在我们这里，原本当唐在哭泣崩溃时，里奇试图解释这只是个玩笑，她对他说了一些话然后走出房间，
but trips and falls. So when we were in this audition room, I was thinking, I'm not gonna trip and fall because it just feels so weird and uncomfortable in this room, not uncomfortable in the good uncomfortable way. Yeah, right. So I didn't.
却绊倒了。所以当我们在那个试镜房间里时，我在想，我才不要绊倒呢，因为在这个房间里感觉太奇怪、太不舒服了，不是那种好的不舒服。是的，没错。所以我没有绊倒。
And then at the end of the scene, Ricky kept going as David Brent. And so I kept going. And then after a while I was like, yeah, I'm probably going to run out of things to say. So what do I do? Oh, I know, I'll just leave the room. So I just exited the room and went. I just heard Ricky roaring. I was like, apparently that was okay. And then I got it. And I was really pleased. And I had to sign a contract, I think, for six years. And that was very new in England. And I remember, isn't this awful?
然后在场景结束时，里奇继续扮演大卫·布伦特。所以我也不得不继续演下去。过了一会儿，我在想，好吧，我可能快没话说了吧。那我该怎么办？哦，我知道了，我只要离开房间就行了。所以我直接走出了房间，然后。我只听到里奇在大笑。我想，这好像还行。然后我就被录用了。我真的很高兴。我想我不得不签了一份为期六年的合同。这在英国非常新颖。我记得，这不是很糟糕吗？
I remember thinking, six years? I don't want to be doing the same thing in six years' time. And now, of course, I couldn't be more glad to have got this job. It was a joy. And the fact that no one said, don't forget, this is a funny line, so really make it funny. Don't, you know, and everything had to just be as real as possible with my comfort zone and my, like no one had ever asked me to do that before. It was all like, be a good actor, but it's acting.
我记得当时在想，六年？我可不想在六年里一直做同样的事情。现在，当然，我再高兴不过能得到这份工作了。这真是一种享受。而且没有人说：“别忘了，这是一句笑话，所以一定要把它演得很有趣。”你知道的，一切都必须尽可能真实，这完全在我的舒适区内，就像以前从来没有人要求我那样做过。所有的表演都是“要做一个好演员，但这就是表演”。
And now this is just being. You were so good though, your timing. And when I watched it the first time, you know, years before the US version, I really didn't think it was scripted. I was one of those people that thought they just, you know, I thought, well, David Brent is a crazy character of a person, but I'd also worked for some really weird bosses. And so I kind of bought it. But I thought you were just in the moment.
而现在这仅仅是存在。不过你演得真好，你的时机把握得太准了。当我第一次看的时候，你知道的，是在美版之前的几年，我真的以为这不是有剧本的。我是那种以为他们只是，你知道的，我认为，好吧，大卫·布伦特是一个疯狂的角色，但我以前也遇到过一些非常奇怪的老板。所以我有点相信了。但我以为你当时只是在情境之中。
Yeah, we were. It was, it was really a joyous freedom. I don't know if you felt this, just to, you know what's happening is also funny, but you just get to be, you just get to be real. No one's trying to make a big thing about a joke and making sure you have three laughs a page and all of that kind of stuff. And that was a freedom for me. I loved it. The rhythm of it, like what Angela's saying and what you're talking about, when I saw it again,
是的，我们确实是。这真的、真的是一种快乐的自由。我不知道你是否有这种感觉，只是去——发生的事情也很有趣，但你只需要做你自己，只需要表现得真实。没有人试图把一个笑话搞得很大，或者确保你每页都有三个笑点之类的。对我来说这是一种自由。我太喜欢了。它的节奏，就像安吉拉所说和你刚才谈到的，当我再次看到它时，
before I ever even knew I was gonna audition, before I even knew there would be this American version, I was just completely struck by how funny it was to be off rhythm and to sit in things for awkward amounts of time. And it was a new comedic rhythm that you guys just invented together. It was so cool.
甚至在我知道我要去试镜之前，在我知道会有这个美版之前，我完全被它那种不合常规的节奏以及在尴尬的时长里保持沉默的搞笑方式给震撼了。这是你们一起创造的一种全新的喜剧节奏。太酷了。
There was a show in England that had already started airing called The Royal Family, R-O-Y-L-E. And that was a similar style. And if you've never seen The Royal Family, please see it. If you guys have never seen it, it's so good. It's so uncomfortable. And it's really just a family on a couch in a living room. And anyway.
英国当时有一个已经开始播出的节目叫《罗伊一家》，拼写是R-O-Y-L-E。那是类似的一种风格。如果你从来没看过《罗伊一家》，请务必看一看。如果你们都没看过，它真的太棒了。让人感到非常尴尬。它其实就是一个家庭坐在客厅的沙发上。总之。
I can't wait to check it out. Yeah, check it out or I'll send you a link. Yeah. But yeah, when I watched that, I remember thinking that would be a fun role as an actor to play. So doing The Office, ever since then, I did my first multicam a couple of years ago. I knew, of course, that the style isn't going to be the office or whatever.
我迫不及待想去看看了。是的，去看看吧，或者我发个链接给你。是的。但是，是的，当我看到那个时，我记得当时想，作为演员能演这样一个角色一定很有趣。所以拍摄《办公室》之后，几年前我拍了我的第一部多镜头情景喜剧。我当然知道这种风格不会是《办公室》那样的。
But it was interesting for me and a strange experience to have to make so much of the comedy lines. I was like, but if they're funny, they're funny. You don't have to add a bell and whistle on it. Yeah. I came from sketch comedy. So when I, my first scene, you know, the first, like few lines I had, I thought, oh, I'm getting fired.
但对我来说，这是一次有趣且奇怪的经历，必须把这么多的喜剧台词都表现出来。我在想，但是如果它们好笑，它们就是好笑的。你不需要在上面添油加醋。是的。我出身于素描喜剧。所以当我的第一场戏，你知道，前几句台词时，我在想，哦，我要被解雇了。
I was doing so much, but I was, cause I was doing that, da da da da da. But it is such a different style. You guys did it so well, but I have a question. When you were filming the pilot, did you feel like, oh, we've got something here. Like this is gonna be a hit. Because we felt that way.
我动作太多了，但我一直在做，因为我在做那个，哒哒哒哒哒。但这真的是一种完全不同的风格。你们演得太棒了，但我有个问题。当你们在拍试播集时，你们有没有觉得，“哦，我们手里有好东西了。这绝对会火。”因为我们当时就是这种感觉。
We didn't know if everything. I wouldn't say a hit. Well, no, but I thought. I thought we had something special. Amazing. I didn't think anyone was gonna watch it. That's how I felt. Yeah, that's the thing. I was like, if people will watch this, it's gonna be a hit. I don't think anyone was going to watch it. That's how I felt. Yeah, that's the thing. I was like, if people will watch this, it's going to be a hit.
我们不知道会不会一切顺利。我不会说一定会火。好吧，不，但我当时想。我觉得我们拍出了特别的东西。太棒了。我以为没人会看。我当时就是这么觉得的。是的，就是这样。我就觉得，如果有人看这个，那它肯定会火。我当时觉得没人会看。我当时就是这么觉得的。是的，就是这样。我就觉得，如果有人看这个，那它肯定会火。
I don't know if they're going to watch it. Is that, that was your experience? That's how I definitely felt. I just remember really praying that it would go because I loved doing this so much. And we may, I think I told you this, Jenna, that we actually made a pilot and then we remade the pilot. And the original pilot, there were some different things. But the biggest difference was there had been this documentary reality show in the very early days called, I think it was called Airline.
我不知道他们会不会看。是这样吗？那是你的经历吗？我当时确实是这么感觉的。我只记得自己真的在祈祷它能顺利播出，因为我太喜欢拍这个了。而且我们可能——我想我跟你说过这个，珍娜，我们实际上先拍了一个试播集，然后又重拍了一遍。在最初的试播集里，有些不同的东西。但最大的不同是，在极早期有一个纪录片真人秀节目，我想它叫《航空公司》。
And it was just cameras following an airline in a smallish airport in England. It became huge and suddenly these people were famous. There was an actor called John Nettles who narrated the documentary. So we had him narrate the pilot to make it as real, this genre and this style. But then I think, I believe, this is such a long time ago now, but I believe they felt that it took time away from story and comedy.
就是镜头跟拍英国一个小机场的一家航空公司。它变得非常火爆，突然这些人就出名了。有一个叫约翰·内特尔斯的演员为这部纪录片配音。所以我们让他在试播集里配音，使其尽可能真实，符合这种流派和风格。但后来我想，我相信——这已经是好久以前的事了——但我想他们觉得这分散了剧情和喜剧的时间。
So we redid it again. Without him. Without the narration. Yeah. The original theme tune just for that pilot was ELO's Mr. Blue Sky. What? That was our original theme song. It was? Yes.
所以我们又重新拍了一遍。没有他。没有旁白。是的。那个试播集最初的主题曲是ELO乐队的《蓝天先生》。什么？那是我们的最初主题曲。是吗？是的。
Yes. Is that? I never knew that. Did you know that? No. I'm getting chills. Did Greg know that? I don't know if Greg knew that, but when Greg gave us a screener of the pilot and we all
是的。是这样吗？我从来不知道这件事。你知道吗？不知道。我起鸡皮疙瘩了。格雷格知道这件事吗？我不知道格雷格是否知道，但当格雷格给我们看了试播集的样片，我们所有人都
got together and we watched it, the theme song was Mr. Blue Sky. You have to ask him if he knew that that was... Because in ours, obviously, it never got aired. Yeah, same. Yeah. But we couldn't... Greg told us, oh, we can't use that song because... Another show nabbed it.
聚在一起看的时候，主题曲就是《蓝天先生》。你得问问他是否知道那是——因为在我们的版本里，显然，它从未播出过。是的，一样。是的。但我们不能——格雷格告诉我们，“哦，我们不能用那首歌，因为……”另一部剧抢先用了。
So then he had a friend who composed the song that we ultimately used. It's a great song, though. It's a great song, though. Yours is a great song, too. Yeah, because obviously ours was Stereophonics. And bless them, which is fine. They didn't give us permission to use their song, Handbangs of Gladrags. So it was kind of rewritten to be that.
所以他有一个朋友创作了我们最终使用的歌曲。不过，那真是一首好歌。不过，那真是一首好歌。你们的那首也很棒。是的，因为显然我们用的是Stereophonics乐队的。承蒙他们厚爱，虽然也可以。他们没有给我们使用他们歌曲的权限，也就是《Gladrags的手提包》。所以这首歌被改写成了那样。
And then when it got big, they said that we could use it, but we liked ours by that point. And originally with Mr. Blue Sky, the opening credits weren't images of Slough. It was David Brent walking into work all proud and pompous in his suit and his briefcase stuff. So yeah, it was pretty different. I love the opening images. We were in London a few years ago.
然后当节目大火时，他们说我们可以用了，但那时候我们已经更喜欢我们自己的歌了。而且最初搭配《蓝天先生》时，片头开场画面也不是斯劳的风景，而是大卫·布伦特穿着西装、拿着公文包，满脸骄傲自负地去上班的样子。所以，是的，非常不同。我太喜欢那些片头画面了。几年前我们在伦敦。
We actually crossed paths and it was so fun. But I was on a train with my husband and kids and we I didn't realize that we were going to go through slough. And so I said to them, we have to get off. And they're like, what? This is our song. And we jumped off really fast just so I could get a picture. And then we jumped back on the train. Did you post the picture? I did, I did. I had to go look for it. So I remember a story that Stephen Merchant told when they first came to visit the set. He said that after the very first episode aired, he was sitting on the train and he
我们实际上偶遇了，真的很有趣。但我当时和丈夫还有孩子们坐在一辆火车上，我们我没意识到我们要穿过斯劳。所以我对他们说，我们得下车。他们一脸茫然，说：什么？这是我们的歌。我们飞快地跳下了车，只为了拍张照片。然后我们又跳上了火车。你发那张照片了吗？发了，发了。我得去找找看。所以我记得史蒂芬·麦道夫讲过一个故事，当他们第一次来探班时。他说，在第一集播出后，他坐在火车上，
overheard a woman asking her friends if she had seen the documentary about the crazy guy in an office. Oh, God. And that the friend said, Oh, that's that's not a real documentary. That's a comedy show. And that the woman said, Oh, well, then it isn't very funny. Oh, that's great. But what was crazy was he said, like, she loved it when she thought it was a documentary. And then when she found out it was a comedy show,
无意中听到一个女性在问她的朋友，有没有看过那个关于办公室里一个疯子的纪录片。哦，天哪。然后那个朋友说，“哦，那不是真实的纪录片。那是喜剧节目。”接着那个女性说，“哦，那它一点都不好笑。”哦，太棒了。但疯狂的是，他说，她以为那是纪录片时觉得棒极了。然后当她发现那是一个喜剧节目时，
she was like, oh, no, no, I don't care for it. But what was the reaction when it came out? Do you remember? Um, it was slow. Um, we were on a network called BBC Two, which tends to have a lot less viewers. I think our... They told... I think Stephen Rickey told me that the pilot got only just a few more viewers than women's bowls.
她就觉得，哦，不，我不喜欢这个。但节目播出时的反应是怎样的？你还记得吗？嗯，反应很慢。嗯，我们在一个叫BBC二台的电视网播出，这个台的观众往往要少得多。我想我们的……他们告诉……我想史蒂芬和里奇告诉我，试播集的收视人数只比女子滚球比赛多一点点。
Yes. Yes. Hold us that too. Yeah. I actually read that it was, in fact, scored one of the lowest ratings in BBC history. Yeah. Yeah. But that was the great thing about, I mean, in England they do this more because A, we
是的。是的。也这样告诉我们。是的。我实际上看到过报道说，事实上，它的收视率创下了BBC历史上的最低纪录之一。是的。是的。但这正是最棒的地方，我的意思是，在英国他们更倾向于这么做，因为第一，我们
only did six episodes as our whole season. So they're already shops. You may as well air them, I guess. And it was BBC Two is not as big a channel as BBC One. So I think it was always just going to air and it just gradually picked up. And over time, but a lot of people did say I thought it was a documentary at first. Yeah. Did you ever have that?
整个季度只拍了六集。所以他们本来就已经拍好了。我想反正也得播吧。而且BBC二台不像BBC一台那么大的频道。所以我想它本来就是要播出的，然后收视率就慢慢回升了。随着时间推移，但很多人确实说过：我一开始以为那是纪录片。是的。你遇到过这种情况吗？
No. I think because we were on like NBC, must-see TV. Right, yeah. And your show had been so popular. Right, right. That everybody knew. I mean, the big hill that we had to climb
没有。我想因为我们是在NBC的“必看电视”时段播出。对，没错。而且你们的节目当时已经非常火爆了。对，对。所以每个人都知道。我的意思是，我们要克服的巨大难关，
was living up to the original. Like there were so many critics and fans who were like, sort of, I feel like, actively rooting for us to fail. Because they didn't want to take anything. Yeah. They didn't want us to like tarnish the reputation of your show. I will say there have been times and certainly back then where people would say to me back then, as if I would want to hear this, oh, it won't do very well.
就是不辜负原版。当时有那么多的评论家和粉丝，感觉他们像是，某种程度上，在积极地盼着我们失败。因为他们不想让步。是的。他们不希望我们玷污你们节目的声誉。我得说，确实有过一些时候，当然是在那个时期，人们会对我那样说，好像我很愿意听到似的，“哦，这个肯定演不好。”
And I was like, wouldn't it be great if it did? Like, it doesn't affect me one way or the other what it does. That's so nice of you. But why would anyone? I find it very, it's just strange when anyone wishes some failure on anyone. I remember getting a pilot once and I got let go before we even taped it. And it's very hard to be let go from a pilot. But when they got picked up, I couldn't have been more happy. And I emailed everyone and said, congrats, it's just live, just move through it. You don't have to hope that someone fails so that you feel better about yourself. So it's, it was quite fascinating that and I bet you did, I bet you did have that a lot.
而我当时想：如果它演好了不是很好吗？这对我演得好坏没有任何影响。你太好了。但为什么会有人？我发现这真的很——当有人希望别人失败时，这太奇怪了。我记得我曾接拍过一个试播集，但在我们录制之前就被解雇了。从一个试播集中被解雇是非常难受的。但当他们被选中投拍时，我高兴极了。我给每个人发了电子邮件说：“恭喜，生活还要继续，继续前行吧。你不需要盼着别人失败来让自己感觉好过一点。”所以，这真的很令人着迷，我敢打赌你肯定也经常遇到这种情况。
But I will tell you that I've watched every episode of your show through 10, 12 times. I bet I know it more than you do. Really? That is so wild to me. When you told me that, that I was like, I mean, well, what did you think? Like, do you remember the first episode you saw? The first one was the pilot. Yeah, I watched it straight from, I can't remember. So I would have been living in England still when it first aired. And I do know if it came out over there, because I think I watched it over here first. So I feel like you might have had a couple seasons out by the time I was watching it. So then I just started watching it.
但我得告诉你，你们节目的每一集我都看过十到十二遍。我敢说我比你还要熟悉它。真的吗？这对我来说太疯狂了。当你告诉我这个的时候，我当时想，我的意思是，好吧，你是怎么想的？比如，你还记得你看到的第一集是什么吗？第一集是试播集。是的，我是从头开始看的，我不记得了。所以当它刚播出时我应该还住在英国。我确实不知道它是否在那里上映过，因为我想我是在这里先看的。所以我觉得我看的时侯，你们可能已经播出好几季了。然后我就开始看了。
And at first, it might be a little strange because you go, oh, that girl's playing my character and that guy's playing his character. But you have to go, no, they've got to find their own feet. And you did. Well, especially the pilot, you know, is almost a shot by shot remake, which when I rewatched the BBC pilot this week,
一开始，可能会觉得有点奇怪，因为你会说，“哦，那个女孩在演我的角色，那个家伙在演他的角色。”但你必须告诉自己，“不，他们必须找到自己的节奏。”而你们确实做到了。嗯，特别是试播集，你知道，几乎是镜头对镜头的重拍，当我这周重温BBC试播集时，
I'd seen it a while back, but I couldn't believe how much of a remake we did. I couldn't believe how much of your performance I stole from you when I watched it. Delight, I couldn't believe, I've stolen so many performances. Has anyone ever stole any of mine. Delighted. Can die happy. So much.
我前段时间看过，但我简直不敢相信我们重拍了那么多。我简直不敢相信我在看的时候偷了你那么多的表演。太高兴了，我简直不敢相信，我偷了那么多的表演。有没有人偷过我的表演。太高兴了。死而无憾了。太多了。
I mean, and I also noticed like this scene with and we'll get into a bigger breakdown, but I noticed the scene with Tim and Lee at the desk when you walk away. I was like, oh, my gosh, like the three of you and then me and Jim and Roy, I was like, oh my gosh, like down to the like carrying in an odd box. Yes. I know.
我的意思是，我还注意到像这一场戏——我们稍后会进行更深入的剖析——但我注意到蒂姆和李在办公桌旁的戏，当你走开的时候。我当时想，哦，天哪，就像你们三个人，然后是我和吉姆与罗伊，我当时想，哦，天哪，甚至连搬着一个奇怪的箱子都一模一样。是的。我知道。
Yes. So what's in the bag? Exactly, what's in the bag? But when I watched it, I always thought there was a bigger story to the big trash bag box thing. And I was like, no, there's nothing. In both pilots. In both pilots, no.
是的。那袋子里装的是什么？没错，袋子里装的是什么？但当我看着它时，我一直觉得那个大垃圾袋盒子背后应该有一个更大的故事。然后我想，不，什么都没有。在两个试播家里。在两个试播家里，都没有。
That's true. I've forgotten that. You'll know it more than I. I'll know yours more than I'll know mine. I'll tell you that. Well, maybe we should take a break and when we come back, we'll start going through the scenes.
确实如此。我都忘了。你比我还要熟悉它。我肯定比了解我自己的更了解你的。我跟你说。好吧，也许我们该休息一下，等回来后，我们开始过一下这些场景。
Yeah, let's do it. You can remind me. ["The New York Times"] Breaking news, McDonald's international menu items are vanishing. McPizza bites missing in Italy. Big Rosti stolen from Germany. Teriyaki chicken sandwich disappears in Japan. An Abysscoth McFlurry blackout in Belgium.
好的，我们开始吧。你可以提醒我一下。["The New York Times"] 突发新闻，麦当劳国际菜单正在消失。意大利失踪了McPizza，德国被偷了大Rosti，日本的照烧鸡肉三明治不翼而飞，比利时发生了Abysscoth麦旋风黑屏事件。
Oh, it's just in. We can now confirm the stolen favorites have resurfaced at McDonald's Canada. The international menu heist. Try them all while you can for a limited time in participating McDonald's in Canada. I'm Kristin Press. And I'm Dovan Heath. We're World Cup winners, Olympians, and the hosts of The Recap Show. Every week we sit down with the icons, disruptors, and game changers on the field and beyond it to talk victories, heartbreaks, and everything in between.
哦，最新消息。我们现在可以确认，这些失窃的最爱已经重新出现在加拿大的麦当劳。国际菜单大劫案。趁着限时，快去加拿大参与活动的麦当劳品尝它们吧。我是克里斯汀·普莱斯。我是多凡·希斯。我们是世界杯冠军、奥运选手，也是《复盘秀》的主持人。每周我们都会与球场内外的偶像、颠覆者和改变游戏规则的人坐在一起，谈论胜利、心碎以及这一切之间的一切。
We've built a space where athletes, changemakers, and people creating the future of women's sports can show up and show off as their full, unapologetic selves. Follow and listen to the Recap Show wherever you get your podcasts. All right, we're back and here we are. We're talking about The Office, episode one, season one. The title of your episode was Downsize. It was written by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant and directed by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant.
我们建立了一个空间，让运动员、变革者和创造女子体育未来的人们能够以真实的、毫无保留的自我出现并展现自我。无论你在哪里收听播客，请关注并收听《复盘秀》。好了，我们回来了，我们继续。我们正在讨论《办公室》第一季第一集。你们那一集的标题是《精简机构》。由里奇·热维斯和史蒂芬·麦道夫编剧，并由里奇·热维斯和史蒂芬·麦道夫执导。
They wrote all of them and directed all of them, right? How did that work? Well, I mean, I guess so. I mean, certainly from my point of view, everyone, they seem to get on very well, obviously. I don't know how you could do that if you don't get on well. They were both extremely, because Ricky was acting in it as well,
所有的剧本都是他们写的，所有的剧集都是他们导演的，对吧？那是怎么运作的？嗯，我的意思是，我想是的。我的意思是，从我的角度来看，每个人，他们似乎相处得非常好，显然。如果你相处得不好，我不知道你怎么能做到这一点。他们两个都非常，因为里奇也在里面演，
obviously, really extremely generous. Ricky kept, oh my God, he made me laugh so much. There were times when I'm like, you're ruining your own show because we would do things. I remember having to come into, the scene was like, come into David Brent's office. I think I have to open a drawer for something and every single take,
显然，真的非常大方。里奇总是——哦，天哪，他把我逗得太厉害了。有时候我在想：“你在毁掉你自己的节目，因为我们总是在搞事情。”我记得有一次我必须走进——那场戏是走进大卫·布伦特的办公室。我想我得拉开一个抽屉拿点东西，每一次拍摄，
Ricky had left me a fresh obscene drawing. I'm supposed to carry on and I'm like, but I can't because it's new. I'm supposed to carry on and I'm like, but I can't because it's new. I'm responding. As soon as Ricky knew he was doing something unexpected that would make you laugh, it would just get bigger next time until just so you couldn't keep going. One time I was actually sent out the room in the scene.
里奇都在里面给我留了一幅新鲜的淫秽画作。我本该接着演下去，但我心里想：我演不下去了，因为这是新的。我本该接着演下去，但我心里想：我演不下去了，因为这是新的。我在做出反应。只要里奇知道他正在做一些会逗笑你的意想不到的事情，下一次他就会变本加厉，直到你根本无法继续下去。有一次我在一场戏里甚至被赶出了房间。
It was when there was Jennifer Taylor Clark, who was the boss. Yeah, yeah. And we were sitting in, ooh, that might have been the pilot, was it? When she said, where's the... The faxes? The faxes.
那是詹妮弗·泰勒·克拉克在的时候，她是老板。对，对。我们坐在，哦，那可能是试播集，对吧？当她说，那个……传真在哪里？传真。
Yes, that's the pilot. I saw these bloopers. Yes. It was like every time you came in to take notes, Ricky had a different like bit he was saying at the top. Oh yeah, I saw these too. Yes. And it was like 20 takes of you just, you couldn't even start the scene.
是的，那是试播集。我看到过这些NG镜头。是的。就好像每次你进去做记录时，里奇在开场时都会说一段不同的台词。哦，对，我也看过这些。是的。大概拍了20条，你根本无法开始这场戏。
You were just trying to enter the room. I was. And he couldn't make you guys stop laughing. And then you hear Steve off camera say, all right, just stop it. Just stop it. Just say it the way it is. Just stop changing it.
你只是试图走进房间。我是这样的。而他让你们停不下来笑。然后你就能听到史蒂芬在画外说：“好了，停下来。直接停下来。就按原本的台词说。别再改了。”
And so after a while, I don't think I might have had, I think I had a line or two. But after a while, once it got to close up for Ricky and Jennifer, it was like, Lucy, maybe you would like to maybe stand out here. And I said, am I being exited from the scene? Yeah. It's a highlight.
所以过了一会儿，我不觉得我有——我想我有一两句台词。但过了一会儿，一旦镜头切到里奇和詹妮弗的特写，大家就会说：“露西，也许你想去外面站一会儿？”我说：“我是被请出这场戏了吗？”是的。这真是一个高光时刻。
I had a few of those. Do you do it? Yes, I had a few. There's a, when Michael Scott is doing the running man to piano, forget it. Cha cha cha cha cha cha cha cha. it. Cha-cha-cha-cha-cha-cha-cha-cha. Yeah. Cha-cha-cha-cha-cha-cha.
我有过好几次这样的经历。你有过吗？是的，我有过好几次。有一个场景是迈克尔·斯科特伴随着钢琴跳跑步人舞，算了吧。恰-恰-恰-恰-恰-恰-恰-恰。算了吧。恰-恰-恰-恰-恰-恰-恰-恰。是的。恰-恰-恰-恰-恰-恰。
They had to get my reaction, which is me not laughing. They had to get my reaction that he couldn't be there. No. Actually, I guess that's the opposite. They had to make him leave so that I could do it with nothing there because I couldn't do it otherwise. Yeah. We did.
他们必须拍到我的反应，也就是我不笑的反应。他们必须拍到我的反应，证明他不在场。不。其实，我想那是反过来的。他们必须让他离开，这样我才能对着空无一物的地方演，因为我否则做不到。是的。我们拍过一堆这样的戏。
We had a bunch of those. When I had to ask her if Roy had ever mercy killed an animal because poor Sprinkles was in the freezer, that we, Jen and I couldn't get through it. They actually were like, we're gonna like go to lunch because you guys are... Yeah, we need to shift in energy. Yeah, we felt the room turn against us. We're like, oh no, we're not gonna mess up everyone's lunch. Did you really find it hard to not laugh through what I call this big group things, like when Andy Bernard comes in singing Sweeney Todd. I love that opening.
当我不得不问她罗伊有没有对动物实施过安乐死，因为可怜的思灵克斯在冰箱里时，珍和我根本无法演下去。他们实际上说：“我们要去吃午饭了，因为你们——”是的，我们需要转换一下能量。是的，我们能感觉到房间里的气氛对我们不友好了。我们在想：“哦不，我们不能搞砸大家的午饭。”你真的觉得在那些我称之为大型群戏的场景中很难不笑出来吗？比如安迪·伯纳德唱着《理发师陶德》走进来的时候。我太喜欢那个开场了。
Yeah, so fun. So fun. That one, you know, they'd put so much work into that. I mean, I would just not make eye contact because I'm like, I can't mess this up. No. Yeah. Yeah. But a conference room scene, when we were there all day, and we would just get loopy. Yeah. And we'd all go. We'd all start just dropping. Yeah. And laughter. Yeah. All right. Let's talk about how this episode opens. Yes. David Brent,
是的，太有趣了。太有趣了。那一场，你知道的，他们为此付出了太多的努力。我的意思是，我只是不和他们对视，因为我在想：“我可不能搞砸这个。”没有。是的。是的。但会议室的戏，当我们在那儿待了一整天时，我们就会变得有点疯癫。是的。然后我们都会开始。我们都会开始崩溃。是的。大笑。是的。好吧。我们来谈谈这一集是怎么开场的。是的。大卫·布伦特，
who is the manager of Wernham Hogg Paper Company's Slough Branch, is interviewing someone about a forklift position. The guy doesn't know how to drive a forklift though. He doesn't have his license. But it's not going to be a problem. It doesn't matter. No, he's going to call his friend Sammy, who he's just going to push him through basically, is how this is going to happen. Can I point out one thing that was cracking me up? There are probably eight outlets
他是沃纳·霍格造纸公司斯劳分公司的经理，正在面试一个叉车职位的应聘者。不过那个人甚至不知道怎么开叉车。他没有驾照。但这不会是个问题。没关系。不，他会打电话给他的朋友萨米，基本上就是由他把这个人硬塞进去，事情就是这样的。我可以指出一个让我觉得搞笑的地方吗？整个场景中，
behind David Brent in this whole scene. I'm like, how many, they go up the whole wall like a strip to plug things in. Yes, I'm like, how many things are you plugging in this office? Was anything plugged in them? No. Unused.
大卫·布伦特身后大概有八个电源插座。我在想，一整面墙上都是用来插东西的插座带，到底有多少个？是的，我在想，你在这个办公室里到底要插多少东西？里面真的插了东西吗？没有。都是闲置的。
Now, is it true you guys shot in a real office? And that I heard a story that like at one point the business next door came over and told you guys to quiet down? Like literally you were sharing the wall space with an actual business. We were, yeah. So this part of the office was disused, not used. I don't know how to speak.
那么，你们是在一个真正的办公室里拍摄的吗？我听说过一个故事，说有一次隔壁公司的生意人过来告诉你们保持安静？就像你们真的是和一家实际运营的公司共用一面墙。是的，我们是。所以办公室的这一部分是废弃不用的，没在使用的。我不知道该怎么说。
And so it was decorated for us. In the original pilot, Brent's office was actually what became our recreation room. And so they kind of switched those around. Yeah. So we were asked to keep the loft down. And I was like, is someone actually complaining about joy? Yes. Is someone actually complaining because someone's having, if we were fighting and screaming and calling each other names, sure, okay, have a go. This, no. What were they doing? What was the other business? I'm like, if you're really grumpy at your job and all you hear is people laughing, you might complain.
所以它是专门为我们装修的。在最初的试播集里，布伦特的办公室实际上成了我们的休息室。所以他们把这两个地方对调了一下。是的。所以我们被要求保持安静。而我在想：“真的有人在抱怨快乐吗？”是的。真的有人在抱怨是因为有人在——如果我们是在打架、尖叫、互相辱骂，那当然可以，来吧，去抱怨。但这个，没有。他们在干什么？那是家什么公司？我在想，如果你对自己的工作很不爽，听到的却全是别人的笑声，你可能确实会抱怨。
I know. You know, I don't know. That's a good question. I don't know. But was it Ricky's laugh? Because Ricky's laugh is really loud. It's loud. It's loud. It's really, really loud.
我知道。你知道的，我不知道。这是个好问题。我不知道。但那是里奇的笑声吗？因为里奇的笑声真的很大。很大声。很大声。声音真的、真的很大。
It's a cackle. They must know we were filming. I mean, like maybe it was part of the scene. Yes. It doesn't matter. They didn't like it. Did you film all the episodes at that same place? Except obviously anything on location,
简直是狂笑。他们肯定知道我们在拍戏。我的意思是，也许那是戏的一部分？是的。没关系。他们就是不喜欢。你们所有的剧集都在那个地方拍的吗？除了显然任何外景，
like the nightclub or... Sure, right. Yeah. Well, I'm curious, like, you know, the first season aired and then became very popular and then you had to go and do the second one and you had to do the Christmas special. Did people figure out where you were filming?
比如夜总会或者……当然，没错。是的。嗯，我很好奇，你知道的，第一季播出后大受欢迎，然后你们不得不去拍第二季，还得拍圣诞特辑。人们有没有发现你们在哪里拍戏？
Did fans come or did this other business suddenly become enamored with you? Yeah, I don't think they complained in season two. I don't remember any press or any fans coming to the studio. That's good. You still had privacy. Yeah. We wanted to ask you about the front reception desk where you sit, because we were asked by Greg and our director, Ken Quapus, to personalize our desk to bring things in from home so it really felt
粉丝会来吗，还是说这家别的公司突然迷恋上你们了？是的，我想他们在第二季没有抱怨。我不记得有任何媒体或粉丝来过工作室。那挺好的。你们依然有隐私。是的。我们想问问你坐的前台接待处，因为格雷格和我们的导演肯·夸普斯要求我们把办公桌个性化，带一些家里的东西来，让它真的感觉
like your workspace. So we brought pictures and little tachiki kind of things. There's a great shot when, you know, in the next scene David Brent comes over to introduce you and there's a great shot of your desk. There's so many things. And I made a list of what you have. What's on it? I took a picture of it. You have a monkey calendar, a snowflake cup. You have two telephones. Two telephones.
就像是你的工作空间。所以我们带了照片和小饰品之类的东西。有个很棒的镜头，你知道的，在下一场戏中，大卫·布伦特过来向你做介绍，有一个非常棒的办公桌特写。上面有好多东西。我列了一张清单，看看你都有什么。上面有什么？我拍了一张照片。你有一个猴子日历，一个雪花杯。你有两部电话。两部电话。
Oh, that's greedy. Mm-hmm. That was nothing to do with me. I don't know why you have two telephones, but you do. So did you put anything on that desk or was it all there for you? I didn't personalize it in terms of what's seen on camera, but I had a ton of stuff that I brought in. I was a bit of a medicine desk for people.
哦，真是贪心。嗯哼。这跟我可没关系。我不知道你为什么会有两部电话，但你确实有。所以那张桌子上的东西都是你放的，还是本来就在那儿？从镜头里能看到的角度来说，我并没有对它进行个性化装饰，但我带了大量的东西放在那儿。对于大家来说，我那儿简直像个小药箱。
It was like, oh, have you got a paracetamol, which is like Tylenol. Tums. Tums or, yeah, I just had, I don't know why. I had so much stuff under there. Oh my gosh, you're the medicine lady. Angela's the sauce lady. Are you? If you need like a, she literally today brought in three little ketchup packets
就好像，“哦，你有扑热息痛吗？”也就是泰诺。或是健胃整肠丸。健胃整肠丸或者，是的，我只是有——我不知道为什么。我在桌子底下塞了好多东西。哦，天哪，你就是药剂师女士。安吉拉是酱料女士。你是吗？如果你需要一个——她今天居然带了三个小番茄酱包
and a salt packet that she saves and then she puts them in a drawer for us. When you walked in and the first person you saw was Jen and you guys hugged and I stood there holding my ketchup packets because you walked in right as I was putting them in the drawer and I was like wondering if you saw me holding ketchup packets. I didn't but I do have a cupboard at home with
和一个盐包，那是她攒下来的，然后她把它们放进我们的抽屉里。当你走进来，你看到的第一个人是珍，你们拥抱了，而我站在那里拿着我的番茄酱包，因为你走进来的时候我正把它们放进抽屉里，我当时还在纳闷你有没有看到我拿着番茄酱包。我没看到，不过我在家里确实有个橱柜，
things like that in. Oh yeah because I do love making a packed lunch. Yes. And you need a portable sauce. I get very happy when I go oh I really need some I've got it. Yeah. I've got a sachet of ketchup. Do you remember when like all of a sudden you couldn't get like the sriracha sauce? Remember? Like it was like in the stores, anyone else, Sam? Sriracha sauce? I remember this, yes.
里面放着那种东西。哦对，因为我很喜欢自己带午餐。是的。你需要便携的酱料。每当我找到时我都会特别高兴：“哦，我真的需要这个，我有了。”是的。我有一小袋番茄酱。你还记得什么时候——就像你突然找不到是拉差辣酱了吗？记得吗？就像它在商店里断货了一样，还有其他人吗，萨姆？是拉差辣酱？我记得这个，是的。
You remember it. Thank you, Sam. I've never eaten sriracha sauce. Well, let me tell you who has sriracha packets. And they're not easy to come by. I have a drawer, I have some sriracha packets. And they're not easy to come by. I have a drawer, I have some sriracha packets. I kind of covet them in my sauce drawer. At least it's not an expensive habit you have. Thank you. Thank you.
你还记得。谢谢你，萨姆。我从来没吃过是拉差辣酱。好吧，让我告诉你谁有是拉差酱包。而且它们可不容易弄到。我有一个抽屉，我有一些是拉差酱包。而且它们可不容易弄到。我有一个抽屉，我有一些是拉差酱包。我在我的酱料抽屉里对它们宝贝得紧。至少这不是个昂贵的爱好。谢谢。谢谢。
Do you remember, like, what was the first scene you shot? Was it this scene where, like, did you kind of shoot in order, like him coming up to your desk or no? What do you remember from that scene? I'm pretty sure we did film in order, except for like, you know, so here's a scene at my desk, and then there might be a scene in Brent's office, and then there might be a scene in the rec room. So we wouldn't necessarily have then gone in order. But we definitely went as in order as possible,
你还记得，比如，你们拍的第一场戏是什么吗？是这场戏吗，就是他走到你桌子前的那场，还是不是按顺序拍的？你对那场戏有什么记忆？我非常确定我们是按顺序拍的，除了像，你知道的，这里有一场在我桌子前的戏，然后可能有一场在布伦特办公室的戏，接着可能有一场在休息室的戏。所以我们不一定完全按顺序来拍。但我们绝对是尽可能按顺序拍摄的，
which was why for me to play Dawn at the end where I get together with Tim, the nice thing about that is everything was played so much in order that it felt like the story that you were playing it out yourself. And that was actually pretty nice. That is really nice. I loved that.
这就是为什么对于我来说，在最后扮演唐和蒂姆在一起的戏时，好的一点是，一切都是按照顺序演得如此到位，以至于感觉就像是你自己在经历那个故事一样。实际上这感觉相当不错。真的挺不错的。我太喜欢了。
I was curious about your wardrobe, your costume for Dawn because I wore my own clothes in the pilot for ours. And I didn't really have a business suit. I just kind of threw together what I had in a color palette of gray. But I didn't know, did you have any input in your look for the show? I mean, I don't think anyone came up and said,
我对你的衣着、为唐准备的服装很好奇，因为在试播集里我穿的是我自己的衣服。而且我也没有什么职业套装。我只是把衣柜里灰色色系的衣服胡乱搭配了一下。但我不知道，对于剧中的造型，你有什么建议吗？我的意思是，我觉得没有人走过来对我说，
I think it was just like, you know, you've really got to just look officey. So that might pretty much be a suit, skirt, and a shirt, and it's dawn, so I'm not like the boss, like Jennifer Taylor Clarke. So it wouldn't be as smart or as expensive or as cute. You know what I mean? It was like soft colors. So before the season started,
感觉就像是，你知道的，你必须要看起来像个办公室职员。所以那大概就是一套西装、裙子和衬衫，而且她是唐，所以我不是老板，不像詹妮弗·泰勒·克拉克。所以不会那么精明、那么昂贵，或者那么可爱。你知道我的意思吗？颜色都是柔和的。所以在新的一季开始之前，
I would go and meet with the wardrobe designer and we would go and walk around Oxford Street and look for... I hate shopping. Hate it. And so wardrobe was always my least favorite part of any job because now I have to go around the shops. So when I came here to America and I was like, they go to the shops for you? Oh, you went with? I was delighted, yeah. Oh my goodness, I'm just putting that together.
我会去和服装设计师会面，我们会去牛津街周围闲逛，寻找——我讨厌购物。讨厌极了。所以服装一直是我任何工作中最不喜欢的部分，因为现在我得逛商店了。所以当我来到美国时，我在想，他们会替你去商店买衣服？哦，你是一起去的？我当时很高兴，是的。哦天哪，我刚刚把这些串联起来。
That's so wild. Trying on 80 million things, spending the whole day. I'd be like, anything, I'll wear anything. You just tell me and I'll wear it. So is that standard? Like if you book a show in the UK, you go with the costume department? I can't remember a job I've done in the UK where I haven't.
太疯狂了。试穿八千万件衣服，花上一整天。我会想，什么都行，我什么都穿。你告诉我，我就穿什么。所以这是标准流程吗？如果你在英国接了一部剧，你会和服装部门一起去买衣服吗？我不记得我在英国做过哪份工作不是这样的。
Yeah. Wow. Yeah. I did a show in the UK for Sky TV. Okay. But my character was in prison. Right, so that might be different. And spent most of the show in a prison jumpsuit.
是的。哇。是的。我在英国为天空电视台拍过一部剧。好吧。但我的角色在监狱里。对，所以那可能不一样。而且大部分时间都穿着囚服。
Got it. Yeah. You can't go to gas for that. No, you can't. You said it was the happiest wardrobe you had ever on a show. When I realized I would be wearing the same thing for most of the show, that I wasn't changing, I didn't have multiple fittings, I was so delighted. And it was like pajamas.
明白了。是的。你不能为此去逛街买衣服。不，你不能。你说这是你在任何剧里穿过的最开心的服装。当我意识到在节目的绝大部分时间里我都穿着同一套衣服，我不用换装，也没有多次试装时，我简直高兴坏了。而且它就像睡衣一样。
It was like nice and like cozy. It was. Didn't hug anywhere. Yeah, that would be a dream. It was the best. You don't have to look at a ton of clothes. But that does explain why you didn't go shopping for a prison jumpsuit. Correct.
它很舒服、很温馨。确实如此。到处都不紧绷。是的，那简直是个梦。太棒了。你不需要看成堆的衣服。但这确实解释了为什么你不用去买囚服。没错。
They might not do that now. It's been a while. It was 2009 when I last worked in England. So well, no, it wasn't 2009, but it's 2009 when I last did a British job. I did Wonder Woman in England in 2016 or something. But again, that was period wardrobe. So you weren't and they were all made by hand. So you weren't going shopping for it. Yeah. Oh, so maybe period wardrobe. Yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah, period wardrobe I wouldn't,
他们现在可能不这么做了。已经有一段时间了。我最后一次在英国工作是在2009年。好吧，不，不是2009年，但我最后一次接英国的工作是在2009年。我在2016年左右在英国拍过《神奇女侠》。但同样，那是年代服装。所以你不用去——而且它们都是手工制作的。所以你不用去买。是的。哦，所以也许年代服装。是的。是的。哦，是的，年代服装我不会，
but regular wardrobe. I've never not been able to shop for it, yeah. Side tangent. Would you come back sometime and talk about Wonder Woman with us? Because I'm also a huge Wonder Woman fan. Love you in it. And would love to have that conversation as well.
但常规服装。我从来没有遇到过不能自己去买的情况，是的。题外话。你以后还会回来和我们聊聊《神奇女侠》吗？因为我也是《神奇女侠》的超级粉丝。非常喜欢你在里面的表演。也很想和你有那样的交流。
In my little curly ginger wig, yeah. I love that look. I love that look. I love that look. Of course. Yay. Put that on our list, Cassie. Well, in this scene at front reception, David Brent is telling Dawn about sort of his drunken night
戴着我那顶卷曲的姜黄色假发，对。我很喜欢那个造型。我喜欢那个造型。我喜欢那个造型。当然。太棒了。把它加到我们的清单上，卡西。好吧，在前面接待处这场戏里，大卫·布伦特正在跟唐讲述他前一天晚上喝醉酒的事，
out, and he's going on and on. And we talked about the timing of how things are said, but for me, it was also about things that were just left out and not said. And one of my favorite quotes from this whole episode is David Brent telling you what professionalism is, telling Don that, and I think we should hear it. Because I'm a professional, and professionism is,
他喋喋不休地说个没完。我们讨论过台词说出口的时机，但对我来说，关键还在于那些被省略、没有说出口的东西。整集里我最喜欢的台词之一，就是大卫·布伦特告诉你什么是专业精神，他对唐也是这么说的，我觉得我们应该听听看。因为我是个专业人士，而专业精神就是，
and that is what I want, okay, that's all. That's it. And professionalism is. And he, okay? That's all. That's it. And professionalism is... And he has no idea what it is. No idea. Yeah. And that is what I want. Was that the scene or was that episode
这就是我想要的，好吧，就这样。就是这样。专业精神就是。然后他，好吧？就这样。就是这样。专业精神是……然后他根本不知道那是什么。完全不知道。是啊。这就是我想要的。是哪场戏还是哪一集来着，
where he says every guy has woken up at the crack of dawn? Crack of dawn, yes. And you're like, what? Because that's the thing that's quoted to me the most. Oh no, really? Really? The crack of dawn. You must get sentences that you've said or something that's quoted to me the most. Oh no, really? Really? You must get sentences that you've said or something that's quoted to you.
他说过每个人都在黎明破晓时醒来？黎明破晓，是的。然后你会想，什么？因为那是对我说得最多的一句台词。哦不，真的吗？真的吗？黎明破晓。你肯定也听过别人对你说出你曾经说过的话或类似的话。哦不，真的吗？真的吗？你肯定也听过别人对你说出你曾经说过的话。
Oh yeah. Yes. Yeah. I think we had, but we might've cut it. Our version of that line, which I think might've gotten cut by standards and practices, I'm trying to think, is every man has sprayed on Pam.
哦，是的。是的。对。我想我们拍过，但后来可能剪掉了。我们那个版本的台词——我觉得可能因为广电标准和尺度而被剪掉了，我在想——是“每个男人都在帕姆身上喷过”。
Oh yeah, that was cut. Oh. Like Pam was like, you know, a spray that you put in your Pam. Oh yeah, that was cut. Like Pam was like, you know, a spray that you put in your Pam before you cook. Yes, I'd forgotten that. There was this line, sprayed on Pam. Oh, those standards and practices. That didn't get past them for sure. You could have said it would have to be bleeped or something.
哦对，那段被剪了。哦。就像帕姆是一个……你知道的，一种喷在你的帕姆上的喷雾。哦对，那段被剪了。就像帕姆是一个……你知道的，你在做饭前喷在你的帕姆上的喷雾。对，我都忘了。有这么句台词，喷在帕姆身上。哦，那些广电标准和尺度。那绝对过不了关。你可以说，这肯定得消音或者怎么样。
All right, so next up, we're gonna meet some more people in the office. We're gonna meet Gareth Keenan, who was played by Mackenzie Crook. And also we're gonna meet Tim Canterbury, played by Martin Freeman, who I read originally auditioned for Gareth, which is so funny because John Krasinski
好了，接下来，我们要见见办公室里的其他人。我们要见吉里斯·基南，由麦肯锡·克鲁克饰演。我们还要见蒂姆·坎特伯雷，由马丁·弗瑞曼饰演。我听说他一开始是为吉里斯去试镜的，这太有趣了，因为约翰·卡拉辛斯基
originally auditioned for Dwight, which is so funny because John Krasinski originally auditioned for Dwight. Oh. Look at that. That's interesting. The similarities. There are a lot of similarities, especially too with character names. Like everything's like one syllable.
一开始是为德怀特试镜的，这太有趣了，因为约翰·卡拉辛斯基一开始是为德怀特试镜的。哦。你看。真有意思。这些相似之处。有很多相似之处，尤其是角色名字。比如全都是单音节的。
It's like Tim, Jim, Don, Pam. That's true, yeah. And then you have two lead characters with first names. Michael Scott and David Brent. Yeah. Yeah. You have two lead characters with first names, Michael Scott and David Brent. Yeah. Yeah.
就像蒂姆、吉姆、唐、帕姆。确实，是的。然后你还有两个名字很长的主角。迈克尔·斯科特和大卫·布伦特。是啊。是啊。你有两个名字很长的主角，迈克尔·斯科特和大卫·布伦特。是啊。是啊。
Well, Gareth was originally written as a large man who was like kind of a big drinker, red in the face and very crude. And they auditioned many, many people, all who they thought were, there were some wonderful auditions, but something just wasn't sitting right. And the casting director, Tracy Gillum, said, what about Mackenzie Crook? And they were like, we love Mackenzie Crook, but it couldn't be more opposite than
嗯，吉里斯一开始被设定成一个体型壮硕的男人，有点喜欢酗酒，满脸通红，非常粗俗。他们试镜了非常非常多的人，他们都觉得——其中有一些很棒的试镜，但就是感觉哪里不对劲。选角导演特雷西·吉勒姆说：“麦肯锡·克鲁克怎么样？”他们就说：“我们喜欢麦肯锡·克鲁克，但这跟我们
what we were originally wanting. But eventually they auditioned him and it was just like that. And he said, the great thing, I think Ricky said, his words are something like, the great thing with Mackenzie Crook is because he's got such little bird-like features, you can make him much more crude. And harsh. And harsh. Because he's a little bird guy. Yeah, yeah.
原本想要的东西简直南辕北辙。”但最终他们还是让他试镜了，结果就是一拍即合。里奇说过一句话很棒，他的大意是：“麦肯锡·克鲁克最大的优点在于，因为他长着一张小鸟般的小巧面孔，所以你可以让他显得更加粗俗。”
Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, and it's going against what you're expecting. 100%. And I think it's really fun how like, and this was true of the Dwight character on our show too, but like, but especially with Mackenzie playing the character is just, you know, the military, like the interest in like all of the order and all of that.
而且刻薄。而且刻薄。因为他是个小鸟依人的家伙。对，对。是的，这说得通。是的，而且这打破了你的预期。百分之百。而且我觉得很有趣的是，像——我们剧里的德怀特角色也是这样，但尤其是麦肯锡来演这个角色时——你知道的，就是军方那种，对所有规章制度的狂热之类的。
It's like. And the need, I mean, same as David Brent really, that importance and ego in how he comes across and how he's perceived in, you know, Assistant Two or Assistant Four. Yeah. Mackenzie was very funny. He made me laugh a lot.
就像。而且那种需求——我是说，跟大卫·布伦特真的挺像的——那种对他言行举止以及他在别人眼中的形象的重视和自负，不管是副主管二号还是副主管四号。是的。麦肯锡非常搞笑。他把我逗得哈哈大笑。
We all did. Well, they start the scene with the scene that we have. It's the whole Wes app. He actually hits Tim in the back of the head with this newspaper. He does. As he enters. As he comes in, I'm like, I was like, any wonder the rest of the episode Tim's trying
我们大家都是。好吧，他们用这场戏拉开了序幕。就是那个韦斯应用程序的梗。他实际上用报纸拍了蒂姆的后脑勺。他确实这么做了。在他进门的时候。当他走进来时，我当时就想，我就想，难怪接下来的那一整集蒂姆都在试图
to block his view of him. He's like, this guy's such a jerk. It's so true. Also, at six minutes and one second, the character of Tim is holding a very tiny dictionary. I saw that too. He's working on something on his computer. He's holding a teeny tiny dictionary. And I thought, I looked it up because I'm like,
挡住视线不看他。他心里肯定在想，这家伙真是个混蛋。太真实了。还有，在第六分零一秒时，蒂姆这个角色手里拿着一本非常小的词典。我也看到了。他在电脑上处理着什么东西。他手里拿着一本迷你小词典。我想——我查了一下，因为我在想，
when did this episode come out? It came out in July of 2001. And I was like, does he need a physical dictionary to check his spelling? I think I would have used one at that time. Maybe so. I did a lot of crosswords and I used a dictionary. Yeah.
这一集是什么时候播出的？它是在2001年7月播出的。我就想，他查个拼写还需要用实体词典吗？我想我当时应该用过吧。也许吧。我以前做过很多纵横字谜游戏，我用过词典。是啊。
Yeah. Yeah. No, our shows, you know, they predate internet stuff, guys. Yeah. So. Our desks had working computers. Not at the beginning, though. Not at the beginning, but eventually.
是啊。是啊。不，我们的剧，你知道的，比互联网时代还要早，伙计们。所以。我们的办公桌上都有能用的电脑。不过一开始没有。一开始没有，但后来有了。
Did you play a lot of Solitaire? Yes. You know we did. Yes. Minecraft. And I played so much Solitaire. I didn't play that. Or not Minecraft, Minesweeper.
你们玩很多纸牌游戏吗？玩过。你知道我们玩过。是的。我的世界。我玩了超级多的纸牌。我没玩那个。或者说不是《我的世界》，是《扫雷》。
Minesweeper. Very stressful. Minesweeper. Minesweeper, very stressful. Minesweeper would stress me out. Yeah. Yeah, sometimes I'd be getting into it and be annoyed if I was having to stop to film and work. Yeah. All right, so now we're gonna meet David Brent's boss, who, like you said, is Jennifer Taylor Clark,
《扫雷》。压力太大了。《扫雷》。《扫雷》，压力太大了。《扫雷》会把我搞得压力山大。对。对，有时候我正玩得起劲，结果不得不停下来去拍戏和工作，这让我很烦。是的。好了，现在我们要见大卫·布伦特的上司了。就像你说的，她叫珍妮弗·泰勒·克拉克，
who is played by Sterling Gallacher? The Sterling Gallacher, yeah. Oh. Wonderful woman. She's so no-nonsense. And she just does not care about any of David's shenanigans. She stays focused. She doesn't take the bait for any of his jokes.
由斯特林·加拉赫饰演？就是那个斯特林·加拉赫，对。哦。了不起的女人。她做事非常干脆利落。她根本不在乎大卫那些恶作剧。她专注于工作。她才不会上当去接他那些笑话呢。
And isn't she brilliant at it? Yes. Sterling, yeah. Sterling became a dear friend. And she's in England now, so I don't really see her, but we are on Instagram. One of them anyway. On one of the chats?
而且她是不是演得太棒了？是的。斯特林，是的。斯特林成了我的挚友。她现在在英国，所以我其实见不到她，但我们在Instagram上有联系。反正是在其中一个上面。在其中一个群聊里？
On one of them, yeah. She's so wonderful. Yeah. This is the scene we were talking about earlier, where Ricky kept improvising the opening line. Yeah. About his tie. About his tie, random.
在其中一个里面，对。她太棒了。是的。这就是我们刚才谈到的那场戏，里奇一直在即兴发挥开场白。是的。关于他的领带。关于他的领带，随机发挥。
But she's trying to talk to him about the agenda for the day, but of course he made you throw it away. But then we get into the news, which is there's going to be redundancies, aka downsizing. And these two branches are going to have to merge and she hasn't decided who's going to merge with the other one yet. They've got to sort of prove themselves. Yeah. And then Chris Finch leaves a message in the middle of this meeting. I mean, so much happens.
但她试图跟他谈论当天的日程安排，当然，他却让你把日程安排给扔了。但接下来我们谈到了新闻，也就是将要进行裁员，也就是精简机构。这两个分公司将不得不合并，而她还没决定到底让哪个分公司并入另一个。他们必须证明自己的实力。是的。然后克里斯·芬奇在这场会议中间留了一条语音留言。我的天，发生了太多事了。
Also, David Brint is completely like panicking. She's like, don't panic, David, David, don't panic. He's like, you just have to sit through all of it. Yeah. I remember doing our version of that scene with Jan and Michael and me sitting in the chair. It's one of my favorites from the series. Took a long time to get through that.
还有，大卫·布伦特完全陷入了恐慌。她说：“别慌，大卫，大卫，别慌。”他就像是说，你只能硬着头皮把这一切听完。是的。我记得我们拍简和迈克尔的那场戏时，我坐在椅子上。那是这系列里我最喜欢的场景之一。拍完那场戏花了很长时间。
But Ricky saying, did no get an agenda, was every time I don't know that I could, I think that was the bit where I was fired from the scene. No get, an agenda. Anytime I got to watch Steve as Michael and Melora as Jan, like Spar, I almost became an audience member. I would lose my place in the scene.
但里奇说“没拿到日程安排吗”，每次我都不知道自己能不能……我觉得那就是我在那场戏里笑场的时候。“没拿到日程安排吗？”每当我看到史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔和梅洛拉饰演的简互相飙戏时，我就几乎成了个观众。我会忘掉自己在戏里的位置。
So I can't even imagine how fun that was to be in those scenes. Yeah, it was. Well now, even though these branches are merging and people are gonna be let go, David Brent has hired a temp. Right. And he's going to show him around the office.
所以我甚至无法想象参演那些戏有多好玩。是的，确实如此。好了，现在，尽管这两个分公司要合并了，人们要被解雇了，但大卫·布伦特却雇了一个临时工。没错。他要带他在办公室里四处熟悉一下。
Yes. I did have a question for you because there's been several David Brent talking heads by this point. And we used to, every once in a while in our talking heads, because we would get multiple alts for the same talking head, they called them the candy bags. We would get to improvise a little bit here and there in those.
是的。我其实有个问题想问你，因为到目前为止已经有好几段大卫·布伦特的独白了。我们以前在拍独白时，每隔一段时间——因为我们会针对同一段独白拍摄好几个不同的备选版本，他们把这叫做“糖果袋”——我们会在那些独白里这里那里地即兴发挥一点。
And I was wondering what your talking heads were like. Did you get to play around at all or were they really scripted? I mean, everything was scripted. We would do a lot of things like like on action, we would often already talk, especially the fewer the people, the easier that would be. He would say, talk your way into the scene. And then when the scene was finished, he wouldn't shout cut, it would carry on. And I don't ever remember, I mean, I'm sure the poor continuity lady had a nightmare because I don't remember anyone coming up and saying about continuity.
我想知道你们的独白是怎样的？你们可以随便发挥吗，还是说完全是按照剧本演的？我的意思是，一切都是按剧本来的。我们会做很多事情，比如一喊开始，我们其实就已经开始说话了，尤其是人越少的时候就越容易。他说：“你们自己聊着进戏吧。”然后当戏演完时，他不会喊停，拍摄会继续下去。而且我不记得——我是说，我敢说那个可怜的场记肯定做噩梦了，因为我不记得有任何人跑过来讨论过连戏的问题。
So yeah, so really we just got to like chat and nothing was exact and you could add things and not add things and they loved that. And what Ricky did, he would, you know, with adding things and doing new things, he would do the most of, but for sure we had the freedom to do that. Oh yeah, I bet you guys, when I watch you guys,
所以，是的，实际上我们就是随便聊天，没有什么是一成不变的，你可以加台词也可以不加，他们非常喜欢这样。而里奇的做法是，你知道的，通过加台词和搞点新花样，他会发挥得最多，但我们确实拥有这样做的自由。哦，是的，我敢打赌你们，当我看着你们的时候，
I was like, you know, I bet they have that freedom as well. You can tell with the bloopers, you know, the amount of times a line will change just on take two or three or four. Yeah. In this sequence where David Brent is showing this temp named Ricky, who was played by Oliver Criss around the office, this is also when we're kind of starting
我就在想，你知道的，我敢打赌他们也有这种自由。从那些NG镜头里就能看出来，你知道的，有时仅仅在第二、第三或第四条里，一句台词就会发生变化。是的。在这段情节中，大卫·布伦特正带着一个名叫里奇的临时工——由奥利弗·克里斯饰演——在办公室里参观，这也是我们开始
to get background reactions from people, we're seeing the scope of the space, the scope of the office. I was really curious how you guys shot. I looked up, your cinematographer was Andy Hollis. Yeah. I love how the show is shot. We obviously stole so much from that with
捕捉到背景人物反应的时候，我们看到了空间的范围，办公室的规模。我很好奇你们是怎么拍摄的。我查了一下，你们的摄影师是安迪·霍利斯。是的。我很喜欢这部剧的拍摄手法。我们显然从中学到了很多，比如
the low angles and the spy shots and all of that. We had two cameras going at a time. Right. We mainly had the one. so much from that with like the low angles and the spy shots and all of that. We had two cameras going at a time. Right. We mainly had the one. OK. Unless, I mean, you know, menopausal here. Unless I literally don't even remember that I was in it at this point. Probably when we did bigger scenes out, like at the pubs or the nightclubs, we may have had more than one. But I remember one. Yeah. Well, in the pilot, it does we may have had more than one, but I remember one.
低角度镜头、偷拍镜头以及诸如此类的东西。我们当时同时开两台摄像机。对。我们主要用一台。学到了很多，比如低角度镜头、偷拍镜头以及诸如此类的东西。我们当时同时开两台摄像机。对。我们主要用一台。好的。除非——我是说，更年期记性差了——除非我真的完全不记得自己当时在这个场景里了。可能当我们拍摄更大的场景时，比如在酒吧或夜总会，我们可能会用不止一台摄像机。但我只记得一台。是的。好吧，在试播集中，确实
Yeah. Well, in the pilot, it does look like you're following the one camera around. Yeah, it does. You don't have sort of like two angles of the same scene. You don't have a wide shot and a tight shot. It looks like just the one. Yeah, and I know because obviously like with yours,
我们可能会用不止一台摄像机，但我只记得一台。是的。好吧，在试播集中，看起来你确实是在跟着唯一的一台摄像机到处走。是的，确实如此。你不会看到同一个场景有两个不同的角度。你不会有一个全景镜头和一个特写镜头。看起来就像只有一台。是的，我知道，因为显然就像你们的剧一样，
the office is one big area. So even if you weren't in a scene, like speaking or part of it, you'd still be in it because you would be caught in the background. Yeah. So you had to be careful. It didn't look like you were playing solitaire. Right. Well, ladies, why don't we take a break?
办公室是一个大区域。所以即使你没有在演一场戏——没有台词或者不是其中一部分——你也依然身处其中，因为你会入镜当背景板。是的。所以你必须小心翼翼。不能看起来像是在玩纸牌游戏。好吧，女士们，我们为什么不休息一下呢？
Because when we come back, David Brent is going to introduce the accounts department. Those three over in the corner. It won't take long to tell you Neutral's ingredients. Vodka, soda, natural flavors. So what should we talk about? No sugar added? Neutral, refreshingly simple. Well, we're back and David is
因为当我们回来时，大卫·布伦特要介绍会计部的员工了。角落里的那三个人。介绍Neutral的成分花不了多长时间。伏特加、苏打水、天然风味。那我们该聊点什么呢？无添加糖？Neutral，清爽简约。好了，我们回来了，大卫正
showing the tip over to the accounting nook. Now there's only an Angela and a Kevin over there. There's not an Oscar. There's not. Who did we have over there? We had Keith. We had the Keith. And Jane, I think.
带着临时工走向会计角的角落。那边只有安吉拉和凯文。没有奥斯卡。确实没有。那边还有谁？我们有基思。我们有基思。还有简，我想。
Yeah, and they have a little moment, and they definitely have that same vibe that we completely copied, which is when David comes over and is like, look at this crazy corner, you know, and it's just like the most drab, expressionless people. Yeah. Plus you're in accounts.
对，他们有个小互动，而且他们绝对有着和我们完全抄袭的一模一样的氛围，也就是大卫走过来时说：“看看这个疯狂的角落，你知道的，”然后那群人简直就是最死气沉沉、面无表情的家伙。对，再加上你在会计部。
Yeah, you're in accounts. What's happening over there? Gareth is going to continue to bother Tim. While David is pointing out all of the just genius details he's added to the office. He makes a big show of a plant. Yeah, we had a plant. We had a plant. Planty. Planty.
对，你在会计部。那边在干什么？吉里斯继续去烦蒂姆。与此同时，大卫正在指出他为办公室增添的所有极具天才的细节。他隆重展示了一盆植物。是的，我们有一盆植物。我们有一盆植物。小绿。小绿。
Yeah. Then he shows off like a big mouth bass. Which we had as well. It came in Daryl's office years later. I feel like I remember that. Little Easter eggs there. Yeah. Yes. And then David is going to introduce Ricky to Gareth.
然后他展示了一条大口黑鲈。我们剧里也有。几年后它出现在达里尔的办公室里。我觉得我记得那个。里面有一些小彩蛋。是的。是的。然后大卫把里奇介绍给吉里斯。
And we get into the assistant regional manager, assistant to the regional manager. Yeah. Yes. And Gareth is really upset because Tim has pulled another prank on him. He has put his stapler in Jell-O and we both had a question about this scene. We did.
然后我们就引入了副区域经理，区域经理助理的助理。是的。吉里斯非常生气，因为蒂姆又对他搞了个恶作剧。他把吉里斯的订书机塞进了果冻里，我们俩对这场戏都有个问题。我们确实有。
At 14 minutes and 39 seconds, the camera swings over to Tim and he is eating, you guys called it jelly. Yeah. We call it jello. Yeah. But he's eating jelly out of a box. Out of a box. It looks like one big square. So how do you make jello then? In a cup? With like water and you have the little packet and you mix it up. Is it like powder? Yeah, powder. Oh, no, so ours is, it's like a rubbery hard thing that you put in a bowl and pour boiling water on. And then it melts.
在14分39秒的时候，镜头转向蒂姆，他正在吃——你们管这叫果冻（jelly）。是的。我们管这叫jello。对。但他是在从盒子里吃果冻。从盒子里。看起来像是一大块方块。那你们平时是怎么做果冻的呢？用杯子？加点水，拿个小包搅拌一下。是粉末状的吗？对，粉末。哦，不，我们的那种是像橡皮一样硬的东西，你把它放进碗里，倒上沸水。然后它就融化了。
The rubbery thing melts. The rubbery thing melts. So the thing he's eating, he's eating the concentrated. I used to, when I ate, because it's not vegetarian, when I ate meat, I would eat it raw. I loved it raw. Does it taste different than once you've put the hot water on it? The flavor's the same.
橡皮状的东西融化了。橡皮状的东西融化了。所以他吃的东西，他吃的是浓缩的。我以前——当我吃肉的时候，因为这不是素食，我会生吃它。我喜欢生吃。它的味道跟加了热水之后的味道不一样吗？味道是一样的。
It's just, it's harder. Oh my gosh. Just sort of like tug at it like you're eating an eraser. Oh my gosh. This is fascinating. I loved it. We both were like, wait, what is he eating in the box? It's like.
只是，它更硬。天哪。就像咬橡皮擦一样拉扯它。我的天。太神奇了。我可喜欢了。我们俩当时都在想：“等等，他在盒子里吃的是什么？”就像是。
I would buy it just to eat that rather than make the jelly. Yeah. So this is interesting because in our episode, when we did this in the pilot and they swing over to Jim, he's eating some jello out of like a little cup. Yeah. Cause they make like pre-made cups, but they're just for eating. You could put them of like a little cup. Yeah. That you, cause they make like pre-made cups, but they're just for eating.
我会买它来直接吃，而不是去做成果冻。是的。所以这就很有意思了，因为在我们的剧里，当我们在试播集中拍这幕时，镜头转向吉姆，他正用一个小杯子吃着果冻。对，因为他们做那种预制好的小杯果冻，就是直接吃的。你可以把它放进——比如小孩子的午餐盒里。是的。是的。没错。对。但我觉得这不像那样有说服力。
You could put them in like a kid's lunchbox. Yeah. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. But it's not as good of a tell, I don't think. Right. Because like Tim is eating the ingredient. It would be like if Jim were holding a box of powdered jello. And then poured it into his mouth.
对。因为蒂姆吃的是原材料。这就好比吉姆手里拿了一盒果冻粉。然后直接倒进嘴里。
Yes. Exactly. That's what I'm trying to get at. It's very clumsily, but yes. Yeah, yeah. And yeah, because I remember that. He was like, wasn't Tim saying something about, I have no idea what happened as he's eating it in the jelly? Yeah.
是的。完全正确。这就是我想表达的意思。虽然表达得很笨拙，但就是这样。是的，是的。而且，是的，因为我记得那个。他就像是一边吃着果冻一边说：“我不知道发生了什么”之类的？是的。
Yeah. I wonder how many people have put their staples in jello and tried to do that since. So many. I think a lot. So many. We see so many pictures. Not only that, I got as a gift a little mini stapler
是的。我在想，自从那以后，有多少人把订书机塞进果冻里并尝试这么做过。非常多。我觉得有很多。非常多。我们看到了好多照片。不仅如此，我还收到过一个小礼物，是一个迷你订书机，
that had been put in a yellow mold that was soap. And so you use the soap and slowly you get the stapler. That's really cute. I know. People are really creative. It is, I have to say. Soap. Geez. All right, so now we have a scene coming up. This is where Dawn is on her lunch break.
被嵌在一个黄色的肥皂模具里。所以你用肥皂洗手，慢慢地就能把订书机用出来。真的很可爱。我知道。人们真的很有创意。不得不说，确实如此。肥皂。天哪。好吧，接下来有一场戏要上演。这是唐在吃午休的时候。
She's trying to read a book. She's eating a sandwich. Oh, is this in the pilot? Yes. Oh, I thought that was later on. Oh, that was really hard to do. That was really hard to do because what you can't tell on camera is the close proximity with which Ricky was standing next to me talking about testicular cancer.
她正试图看一本书。她正在吃三明治。哦，这是在试播集里吗？是的。哦，我还以为那是后面才有的呢。哦，那场戏演起来太难了。太难演了，因为你在镜头前看不出来的是，里奇当时离我站得非常近，在跟我谈论睾丸癌。
And grabbing his balls. And since you're seated and he's standing, your face is exactly even with his crotch. Right there. Yeah. And I didn't, and because it was the pilot, we weren't so used to, you know, how this was going to play out and how this was going to be. So when I sat there and I had already this bit of Brie sandwich in my mouth, that's another line I get a lot of,
而且还抓着自己的蛋蛋。因为你是坐着的，而他是站着的，你的脸正好跟他的裆部齐平。就在那儿。是的。而且我——因为那是试播集，我们还不太习惯，你知道的，这戏接下来会怎么发展，会拍成什么样。所以当我坐在那儿，嘴里已经塞了一块布利干酪三明治时——这也是我经常听到别人学的一句台词，
bit of Brie. Bit of Brie. Bit of Brie. And I turn, what you can't, you just can't, you know this, you just can't tell it on camera because you know on camera you have to stand closer to someone than you would in real life. Right. In real life it would be like, it's so awkward that you were this close, but for camera you have to be close.
“一块布利干酪”。一块布利干酪。一块布利干酪。当我转过头时，你根本——你懂的，你在镜头前就是看不出来，因为你知道在镜头前你必须比现实生活中站得离对方更近。没错。在现实生活中，离得这么近会尴尬得要命，但为了镜头，你必须离得很近。
Who was close? I'm not going to lie. And I didn't have to hold the brie sandwich in my cheek. It just wouldn't go down. But it was a wonderful, wonderful little moment of seeing. We shot that same scene for our pilot. That was my other audition scene. So I had the fake firing scene as my audition scene.
谁离得近？我实话实说。我其实没必要把布利干酪三明治塞在腮帮子里。它就是咽不下去。但那是一个非常精彩、非常美妙的小表演时刻。我们在试播集里也拍了那场戏。那是我另一次试镜的戏份。所以我有那场假解雇戏作为试镜戏。
And then I had this eating lunch scene. But ours got cut. I know, it didn't make it in for time. Because we had to get our episodes down to like 21 minutes, 30 seconds. Oh, that's hard. So we were like 29 and a half. Yeah, you guys had extra time.
然后我还有这场吃午饭的戏。但我们的被剪掉了。我知道，因为时间不够没能播出来。因为我们必须把每集时长控制在大约21分30秒。哦，那太难了。所以我们当时超长了，大概有29分半。是的，你们有额外的时间。
Yeah, yeah. But this sort of like physicality where you're in someone's space awkwardly, I feel like just kept coming back, especially for Michael Scott. Like he would talk to Jim and put his foot up on the desk. Like basically lean in, so it's just like crotch facing you. And there were a lot of moments like that.
对，对。但这种肢体语言，就是你尴尬地闯入别人的私人空间，我觉得这一直在重现，特别是对迈克尔·斯科特来说。比如他会跟吉姆说话，然后把脚踩在办公桌上。基本上就是身体前倾，所以基本上就是裆部对着你。有很多这样的时刻。
I love those things, especially when when if they're not in the scripts and you're not expecting them at all. Yeah. I mean, obviously this brief scene was scripted, so I knew what the script was and the lines were, but I just didn't plan on having Ricky's crotch quite so clear to my brain. Quite so close. It didn't count for that one ball to be so close to your sandwich. It was, yeah. Speaking of not being able to swallow your brie and breaking, you know, we broke all the time, but there were a few people that broke the most.
我特别喜欢那种细节，尤其是当它们不在剧本里，而你完全意想不到的时候。是的。我的意思是，显然这场布利三明治的戏是写进剧本里的，所以我知道剧本是什么，台词是什么，但我只是没料到里奇的裆部会离我的大脑那么近。离得那么近。我没算过那颗蛋蛋离我的三明治竟然能这么近。它确实，是的。说到咽不下布利干酪和笑场，你知道的，我们总是笑场，但有几个人笑得最厉害。
Like, Rainn Wilson cracks himself up. He broke as Dwight a lot. Mindy broke in almost every scene. I remember Mindy doing the character doing the cabbage soup diet and looking awful. I will do this now and I'll know if someone watches your show well. Because she'll go, "'You kind of look amazing.'" LAUGHS Oh, I love it. OK, so Mindy cracks up a lot. Yes, yes. But so on your set,
比如雷恩·威尔逊经常把自己逗笑。他演德怀特时笑场很多。明迪几乎每场戏都笑场。我记得明迪演那个卷心菜汤减肥法的时候，那造型难看极了。我现在学这个，就能看出谁对你们的剧看过头了。因为她会说：“你看起来简直棒极了。”笑声哦，我太喜欢了。好吧，所以明迪经常笑场。是的，是的。但在你们的片场，
now we know you had to exit a scene, but was there someone that broke the most? Was it Ricky? Probably Ricky, but he broke more because he would see us breaking or trying not to. There was a scene, I think you might have seen it in Bloopers, where Ricky and Martin are doing a scene. It's the job evaluation scene. And I came in to do my job evaluation scene, and they were already nowhere near finished.
现在我们知道你得走出镜头，但有没有谁是笑场最多的？是里奇吗？可能是里奇，但他笑得更多是因为他看到我们在笑，或者在极力忍住不笑。有个场景——我想你可能在NG镜头里看过——里奇和马丁在拍一场戏。那是绩效评估的那场戏。我走进去准备演我的绩效评估戏，而他们俩当时离拍完还差得十万八千里呢。
So we went over and over to lunch, and then had to go back to it over lunch. So because they couldn't get through it. I saw that blooper and they keep clacking the clacker, and it was upwards of 30 takes. Oh my goodness. Yes, and there was this moment that I remember from watching the show that was breaking them up
于是我们拍了一遍又一遍直到午饭时间，午饭后还得接着拍。因为他们根本拍不下去。我看到过那个NG镜头，他们一直在啪啪地打板，拍了差不多有30条之多。哦天哪。是的，而且我记得看剧时有个瞬间把他们两个都逗笑了，
and it's so funny, it's just a gesture that where Ricky is saying, if you play your cards right, someday you might be in this chair. The hands. Yeah, and he does this like point down to his seat and like bites his lip. He's like, mm. Yeah.
真的太搞笑了，那只是个手势，里奇说：“如果你表现得好的话，总有一天你也能坐上这把椅子。”那个手势。是的，他做了一个向下指着自己座位的动作，还咬了咬嘴唇。他就像是：嗯。是的。
And the first time he did it, they both broke. And they're like, no, no, no, we gotta get that. We gotta get that, do that again, do that again. But they never, I don't know how they ever got through it. It was, but it was so funny. Especially as it would get bigger. I remember doing a scene later where Ricky is playing the guitar for me. Yes.
第一次他做这个动作时，两人都笑场了。他们说：“不，不，不，我们得把这个拍下来。我们得把它拍下来，再来一次，再来一次。”但他们根本——我不知道他们是怎么把那场戏拍完的。真的太搞笑了。尤其是随着动作越来越夸张。我记得后来拍了一场戏，里奇为我弹吉他。是的。
In his office. Yes. It's so funny. It really is. And that was hard. I had written a song, oh my God, when I was 15, where I played the piano and sang this song. It was for my GCSE music, which is, I don't know, whatever exams you take here when you're 16. And I got an A for my music. It's the only thing I ever got an A in.
在他的办公室里。是的。太搞笑了。确实如此。那真的很难。我写过一首歌，天哪，我15岁的时候写的，我一边弹钢琴一边唱这首歌。那是为了我的GCSE音乐考试，也就是，我不知道，你在16岁时这里参加的什么考试。我的音乐得了A。那是我唯一得过A的科目。
It was so bad because it was also kind of good, but it was a really cheery ditty that I was like, and yet it was about the most horrific things, pedophiles. Oh no. And I'm not religious at all, but in the chorus it would be like, at the end of the worrying terror, there's heaven not far away.
这歌太糟糕了，因为它其实也挺不错的，但它是一首欢快的轻歌曼唱，我当时就想——然而它唱的内容却是最可怕的事情，恋童癖。哦不。而且我一点也不信教，但在副歌部分它会唱到：在焦虑和恐惧的尽头，天堂并不遥远。
And I remember telling Ricky and Steve this and they were like, we have to have this in our show. They worked their asses off in season two to try and get it in. I couldn't find a way to legitimately get it in. It was so bad and it was so good because it was so bad. Yeah. It was crap-tastic. This was, I feel like this story is why you were destined to be cast on this show.
我记得我把这事告诉里奇和史蒂夫时，他们俩的反应是：“我们必须把它写进我们的剧里。”他们在第二季里拼了老命想把它塞进去。但我找不到一个合情合理的方法把它塞进去。这歌太烂了，但又因为太烂而显得很棒。是的。简直是“烂并精彩着”。我觉得这个故事就是你命中注定要参演这部剧的原因。
Because your senses of humor were so aligned. This idea of like a song about all the things you kind of aren't supposed to say or discuss in a peppy manner. In like a peppy show tune. Yeah, it entered my head at 15. It was like a peppy show tune. Never entered my head at 15. It was like a peppy show tune that could have opened a sitcom. Yes, and about the darkest stuff. Yeah, about the darkest stuff, not religious at all.
因为你们的幽默感太合拍了。这种用欢快的语调去唱那些你本来不该说、不该讨论的事情的想法。用那种欢快的喜剧曲调。是的，我15岁时脑子里就冒出这个了。就像一首欢快的喜剧曲调。我15岁时脑子里可从没想过这个。这就像一首本可以作为情景喜剧开场曲的欢快曲调。是的，而且内容是最黑暗的东西。是的，关于最黑暗的东西，而且一点也不宗教。
And I went, I desire a Micah prophesized, a friendly world of peace. What? Did they? I have no idea. But you got an A. I got an A. You got an A. So bar was low. They might have just been in shock, didn't know what to make of it. I think it was like, poor girl. She's going nowhere in life. Let's give her something. No. All right, there's gonna be a conference room meeting. We have to discuss conference room scenes with you. David Brent is going to discuss these rumors of downsizing.
我当时唱：“我渴望先知米迦勒预言的那个充满和平的友善世界。”什么？他们真的这么干了？我不知道。但你拿了个A。我拿了个A。你拿了个A。所以标准真是低啊。他们当时可能只是震惊了，不知道该怎么评价。我觉得当时的情况就像是：“这可怜的女孩。她的人生没前途了。给她个好成绩吧。”才没有呢。好吧，接下来有一场会议室的会议。我们得跟你聊聊会议室的戏。大卫·布伦特要讨论这些关于精简机构的传闻。
How was this to shoot? Okay. Probably very like your conference scenes, which they take a long time. Yeah. And at first you are genuinely trying to like be professional. Let's get it done guys. Come on. Do you know what I mean?
拍这场戏感觉怎么样？还行。可能跟你们的会议室戏很像，都要拍很长时间。是的。一开始你真的是在努力表现得专业。大家快完成吧。加油。你知道我的意思吗？
This is fine. And then of course, as Rick is doing his speech and all of this, he'll change his speech and so you're listening and so you're doing it. And then I have one bit where I was doing, I had a line, something like, well, Jennifer said there might be some job losses or downsizing. Yes. He calls on you hoping that you're going to save the day, but instead you make it worse. And Ricky was sitting, Steve was sitting at the monitors for me doing this line.
这很好。然后当然了，随着里奇开始发表他的演讲以及各种发挥，他会临时改变台词，所以你得听着，然后跟着反应。然后我有一段戏，我当时有一句台词，大概是：“珍妮弗说过可能会有一些岗位流失或精简机构。”是的。他点名让你发言，希望你能挽救局面，但你反而把它搞得更糟了。里奇正坐在监视器前，史蒂夫也在那儿看着我念这句台词。
And I did it. The note was, a little less soap opera loose. And I went, oh, okay. I think because I had this one line in this long scene, I think I might have been trying to really make it last a while. Make a meal. Yeah. So I made it less soapy. That made me just have a question.
我念完之后。得到的反馈是：稍微少一点肥皂剧的松散感。我就说：“哦，好吧。”我想是因为我在这个冗长的场景里只有这么一句台词，我当时可能真的想把它拖得久一点。加点戏份。是的。所以我演得没那么像肥皂剧了。这让我突然想问一个问题。
So was he the one usually yelling things off camera to you guys? Was he, they co-directed, but was Stephen Merchant more the one sort of like yelling action, giving notes and stuff like that? Yeah, I think Steve would have done action more or our first AD, more so if Rick is in the scene. If he's not in the scene, he's usually changed back into his sweats and chomping on a sandwich, watching the monitor. But yeah, so that would be Steve normally.
所以平时通常是他在镜头外对你们大喊大叫吗？是他在——他们是联合导演，但史蒂夫·莫昌特是不是更像那种负责喊“开始”、给意见之类的人？是的，我觉得如果是里奇在戏里的话，通常会由史蒂夫来喊开始，或者由我们的第一副导演来喊。如果他不在这场戏里，他通常会换回运动裤，一边啃着三明治，一边看着监视器。所以，是的，所以通常那都是史蒂夫的工作。
Yeah, that makes sense. It's kind of fun, like co-directing and acting in the thing that you've written. I can't really, that seems so written. Yeah. I can't. Really? That seems so stressful to me. You would like that, Angela. I feel like because you have the all creative brain.
是的，这说得通。联合导演自己写的东西并亲自参演，这挺有意思的。我真的——这听起来太高难度了。我做不到。真的吗？这听起来压力太大了。你会喜欢这种的，安吉拉。我觉得因为你拥有全方位的创作大脑。
I don't. Right. I can't direct. I don't know if I could direct, actually. I would love that, but I would love to have you there with me, Jenna. Because then. What am I doing?
我可没有。对。我不会导演。事实上我不知道自己能不能当导演。我会很喜欢那样，但我希望你能在旁边陪着我，珍娜。因为这样的话。我在干嘛？
You're doing what Steven was doing. Oh, I'm your Steven Merchant. Yes. Oh, I do that. Exactly. So you could sort of like be the eye outside the scene and I'm in it. Oh, now I'm directing again, which I think I can't do. Oh, OK.
你在做史蒂夫在做的事。哦，我是你的史蒂夫·莫昌特。对啊。哦，我可以这样。完全可以。所以你可以充当戏外的眼睛，而我身处戏中。哦，现在我又在导演了，我觉得我根本做不到。哦，好吧。
Well. I don't know if my brain goes there to direct. I like producing. Yeah. I really enjoyed that side of my career. And I obviously love acting. But yeah, the directing, I'm like, my little brain,
好吧。我不知道我的大脑能不能转到导演那个频道上去。我喜欢制片。是的。我真的很享受我职业生涯的那一部分。而且我显然热爱表演。但导演嘛，我觉得，我那小脑袋瓜，
I don't know if I could take it all in. You've got to be aware of every single area ever going on. And I think my brain would explode. I'm also such an inside out performer as an actor. So like, I'm very much about like, what am I feeling? What do I want? What's motivating me?
我不知道自己能不能承受这一切。你必须对正在发生的每一个微小的角落都了如指掌。我觉得我的大脑会爆炸。而且作为一个演员，我是一个由内而外的表演者。所以，比如，我非常关注：我的感受是什么？我想要什么？是什么在激励我？
And I'm not really aware of my surroundings. Like, I'm not good at decorating a room. Like, I don't know where to put the chair and the couch and the things. And my husband, who's a director, like, he's really good at that. Like, he knows how to build a visual picture. Right.
我其实并不太关注周遭的环境。比如，我不擅长装修房间。比如，我不知道该把椅子、沙发和各种东西放在哪里。而我丈夫是个导演，他在这方面真的很在行。比如，他知道如何构建一个视觉画面。没错。
I just know how to like, come from like, sort of an emotional place. Got it. Yeah. I think. Yeah. So that's why I think I can't direct. Maybe. I don't know.
我只知道如何从——某种情感层面出发来表演。明白了。对。所以这就是为什么我觉得我当不了导演。也许吧。我不知道。
I don't know. Don't say never, lady. You'd be surprised. Don't say never. Well, I did sign us up. We'll all direct together. I did sign us up to direct a show together, me and you. Oh dear.
我不知道。别说绝不，女士。你会大吃一惊的。别说绝不。好吧，我确实替我们报过名。我们要一起导演一个节目，我和你。噢天哪。
No, I'm kidding. We'll all direct something together, but we'll really leave it to Angela. No. I like to Angela. No. I like this idea. Yeah, and we can sit and have coffee. How many directors do you have? Three. Three.
不，我开玩笑的。我们以后会一起导演点什么的，但我们肯定会把导演工作完全交给安吉拉。不。我喜欢安吉拉。不。我喜欢这个主意。对，我们可以坐在那儿喝咖啡。你们有多少个导演？三个。三个。
Technically one, but. Okay, we have to talk about this moment where Don is attempting to fix Tim's hair. And you have like these great fingernails and you're kind of going through his hair. How much of that moment was improvised between the two of you? All of it.
严格来说是一个，但是。好吧，我们必须聊聊这个时刻：唐正试图帮蒂姆整理头发。你有着那么好看的长指甲，手在人家头发里穿来穿去。你们俩之间这个瞬间有多少是即兴发挥的？全是即兴的。
So what was the idea? The idea was like, okay, we need to see you guys be kind of flirty. Like, yeah, just watching it. You know that moment, you know, well, you know when you fancy someone, but you've never acknowledged it between you. So really what you're trying to do is engage in some way.
那当时的设想是什么？当时的设想是：好吧，我们需要看到你们俩表现得有点调情。就像，是的，光是看着这一幕。你知道那种感觉，你知道的——当你对某人有好感，但你们之间从来没有挑明过。所以你真正想做的是通过某种方式产生互动。
Of course, touch is always a nice thing to get in and I'll do anything for some. I mean, I remember improvising a scene and I said to Tim, play with my hair in the scene. I was like, oh, this is a great way of getting a massage. Yes. Just telling him to, like in the scene. And I was like, oh, this is a great way of getting like a massage. Yeah. Just telling him to do it in the scene. But yeah, a lot of our scenes like that were improvised, just play together. Martin really helped me in those because I wasn't as confident then.
当然，肢体接触总是一种拉近距离的好方法，为了能有点接触我什么都愿意做。我的意思是，我记得有一次即兴演一场戏时，我对蒂姆说：“在这场戏里玩我的头发吧。”我当时就想：“哦，这真是享受按摩的好办法。”是的。只要告诉他——就像在这场戏里那样。我当时就想：“哦，这真是享受按摩的好办法。”是的。只要在戏里告诉他这么做就行。但确实，我们很多这样的戏都是即兴发挥的，就是互相配合。马丁在这方面帮了我很多，因为那时我没有现在这么自信。
Now I'd love to do things like that. And I've done a lot of improv-profit groundlings at UCB. But I was much more nervous of it then. And Martin was just great chatting away. So I really, I relied on him and I'm grateful to him for that. Did you guys have to do like chemistry reads as part of your audition process? No. Really? Yeah. So how did they know you guys were gonna do like chemistry reads as part of your audition process? No. Really?
现在我很乐意做那样的事情。我曾在命运台剧团和UCB做过很多即兴表演。但当时我紧张得多。而马丁总是很会聊天。所以我真的很依赖他，对此我非常感激你们需要把化学反应测试作为试镜流程的一部分吗？没有。真的吗？对。那他们怎么知道你们俩——需要把化学反应测试作为试镜流程的一部分吗？没有。真的吗？
Yeah. So you, how did they know you guys were going to be so great together? I don't know, that's a very good point. I mean, I did two castings and the last one was with Ricky and Asha Teller, our producer and Steve and casting and that was it. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, you guys, the chemistry between you two and and it's just so like, oh my gosh.
对。那他们怎么知道你们俩在一起会这么棒呢？我不知道，这真是个好问题。我的意思是，我参加了两次试镜，最后一次是和里奇、我们的制片人阿莎·泰勒、史蒂夫以及选角导演一起，然后就定下来了。是的。是的。哦，你们俩之间的化学反应——那感觉简直是，哦天哪。
You're just rooting for Don and Tim. You're just rooting for them. Oh, it was a really, but Ricky always said, people come for the comedy, but stay for the story. And I think that's probably good in any comedy show. I mean, you guys have so many great stories playing out, your relationship with Dwight. And you remember that the office is funny
你就是会忍不住为唐和蒂姆加油。你就是会支持他们。哦，这真的是一个——但里奇总是说：“人们是为了喜剧而来，却为了故事而留下来。”我觉得这对任何喜剧节目来说可能都是至理名言。我的意思是，你们剧里有那么多精彩的故事在展开，比如你和德怀特的关系。你会记得办公室很搞笑，
and you come for that and you laugh your head off. But you see all of these stories with characters you love play out and have time and have lengths of time to do it. And it's why you keep coming back, I think. Yeah, for sure. That's, for me, I'm like, what is the heart of the show? It's the people and the connections they make. Yeah.
你为了这个来看剧，然后笑得前仰后合。但你会看到所有这些你喜爱的角色的故事在徐徐展开，并且有充足的时间去铺陈。我想这就是为什么你会一直不断地回头重温这部剧。是的，绝对的。对我来说，我在想：这部剧的核心是什么？是人，以及他们之间建立的联系。是的。
Well, unfortunately, Dawn's fiance, Lee, is gonna arrive. This is a big shock. We're not expecting it. No. Lee with his giant garbage bag box thing. Yes, because Tim was just suggesting that y'all go out and get drinks. And so all of our hearts are swooning, of course. But no.
好吧，不幸的是，唐的未婚夫李要登场了。这是一个巨大的打击。我们完全没有预料到。没有。李带着他那个巨大的垃圾袋包装的盒子。是的，因为蒂姆刚才还在建议你们俩出去喝一杯。所以我们所有人的心当然都为之融化了。但并没有。
And then they have that awkward, awkward silence. Oh, it's so good. And then Tim says, what's in the? And he goes, just tell her I'll be outside. Yes. It's so awkward. He's like, I'm not going to talk to you, man. And I love that they never made the character of Lee a bad person.
然后他们陷入了那种尴尬至极的沉默。哦，太棒了。然后蒂姆问：“这里面装的是什么？”李说：“告诉她我在外面等她。”是的。太尴尬了。他就好像在说：“我才不跟你这家伙说话呢。”我喜欢的是，他们从来没有把李这个角色塑造得十恶不赦。
He was never a baddie. You know, part of you might think, well, maybe he beats her or maybe he's cheated on her. No, he's just not someone you want her to be with. He's not her person. He's not her person. Yeah. And you could call him things like a loser, blah, blah, blah. But he's not. He's decent enough.
他从来不是个反派。你知道的，你的一部分可能会想，嗯，也许他虐待她，或者也许他出轨了。不，他只是不是那个你想让她在一起的人。他不是她的真命天子。他不是她的真命天子。是的。你可以叫他诸如此类的失败者之类的称呼。但他并不是。他算是个正派人。
Yeah. Yeah. But it's a, one of those things where so many people settle because maybe they're looking for marriage and some, some kind of continuity or consistency and, and they settle and that's what Dawn has done for all of her life until the very end. You know, she didn't pursue her dream with the drawing. She didn't pursue Tim and, and she stayed with this guy just because it was easier to stay than go, I think. Yeah.
是的。是的。但这是一种——有很多人将就着过日子，也许是因为他们在寻找婚姻、某种连续性或稳定性，于是他们将就了，而这就是唐在大结局之前一辈子都在做的事情。你知道的，她没有去追求画画的梦想。她没有去追求蒂姆，她只是跟这个家伙在一起，因为我觉得留着比离开更容易。是的。
And how many, I mean, I've done it before. Yeah, yeah. No, and I do like that Lee's not a bad guy and I liked that Roy wasn't a bad guy. And one of the things I did love, of course, we had many more seasons and time to show the storyline than you guys did, but I love that Roy found his person. Right?
而且有多少人——我的意思是，我也曾经这样过。是的，是的。不，我确实觉得李不是个坏人，我也喜欢罗伊不是个坏人。我非常喜欢的一点是——当然，比起你们，我们有更多季的时间来展现这个故事线——我喜欢罗伊找到了属于他的真命天子。对吧？
And learned how to play the piano for her wedding. I mean, it just goes to show that he was meant to be happier too, just the way that Pam was. And, but yeah, so I did like that they didn't make him like sort of this villain person. Yeah. He just wasn't her person. Yeah.
而且还为了她的婚礼去学了弹钢琴。我的意思是，这恰恰说明他也是注定会更幸福的，就像帕姆一样。而且，是的，所以我确实很喜欢他们没有把他塑造成那种反派人物。是的。他只是不是她的真命天子。是的。
It just wasn't her person and he wasn't a bad person. You just looked at him and knew, please don't end up with him. Right. Please don't. Because he's just going nowhere. He doesn't have any, he doesn't encourage her in any kind of dreams whatsoever. Yeah. He doesn't have dreams for himself.
这真的不是她的真命天子，而且他也不是个坏人。你只要看着他就会明白，千万别跟他在一起。对。千万别。因为他根本一事无成。他没有任何，他根本不支持她的任何梦想。对啊。他对自己也没有什么梦想。
And I think that's a shame for anyone. She lights up around Tim and her light goes out around Lee. And you just see it in how you played the character. And when I talk about stealing things from you, that was like something that I really noticed in your performance. And I thought, okay, yes, I like this. I like this way that you have different body language around these two different people. Right.
我觉得这对任何人来说都是一种遗憾。她跟蒂姆在一起时神采奕奕，跟李在一起时就黯淡无光。你在塑造角色时的表现中就能看出来。当我说我从你身上“偷”东西时，那真的是我在你的表演中特别注意到的一点。我想，好的，没错，我喜欢这个。我喜欢你在面对这两个不同的人时表现出的不同肢体语言。没错。
And so, yeah. Yeah. I remember doing the scene at the end of the Christmas specials where Dawn goes home in the taxi with Lee. Yes. Yeah. And then she opens. Oh, it's giving me chills just thinking about it. She opens the paints. Yes.
所以，对啊。对。我记得在圣诞特别篇的结尾拍那场戏，道恩和李坐出租车回家。对。对。然后她打开——哦，光是想想我就起鸡皮疙瘩了。她打开颜料。对。
Just never give up. And just before we filmed that, Steve Merchant came up to me and he said, I'm going to tell you how I'm imagining the scene. I went, okay. And then he said, imagine you open it and then we're going to pull in on you with the camera. it and then we're going to like pull in on you with the camera and just one solitary tear comes down your right eye and I went, geez, Lou, I said, have a word, go home. But I think one did, weirdly. I don't know how many takes we had to do for me to like do that. Sometimes I can cry
千万不要放弃。就在我们拍摄那场戏之前，史蒂夫·莫昌特走到我面前对我说：“我要告诉你我是怎么构思这场戏的。”我说：“好啊。”然后他说：“想象你把它打开，然后摄像机要推近拍你。把它们打开，然后摄像机推近拍你，一滴孤独的眼泪从你的右眼流下来。”我当时就想：“天哪，老兄，我说，你认真的吗，回家去吧。”但我奇怪的是，好像还真流了一滴。我不知道我们拍了多少条我才做到那种效果。有时候我能
naturally and sometimes I have to stick Vic in my eye. Same. Yeah. Same. In this scene where David Brent fake fires you and you have to break down crying, how many times did you have to do that? Do you remember? And was that more like,
自然地哭出来，有时候我不得不拿眼药水往眼睛里戳。我也是。对。我也是。在戴夫·布伦特假装解雇你、你情绪崩溃大哭的那场戏里，你拍了多少次？你还记得吗？那更像是……
did you get yourself really crying? You look like you're pretty upset. I didn't really cry in that scene. I think I put my head in my hands, right? Yeah. You look like you're pretty upset. I didn't really cry in that scene. I think I put my head in my hands, right? Yeah. I think I did that probably to disguise the fact that I wasn't crying.
你是真的把自己弄哭了吗？你看起来真的很沮丧。我那场戏其实没哭。我想我是把脸埋在手心里了，对吧？对。你看起来真的很沮丧。我那场戏其实没哭。我想我是把脸埋在手心里了，对吧？对。我想我这么做大概是为了掩饰我没哭的事实。
I know that trick. And then you get the breathing and you're like, yeah, yeah, yeah. The sniffling. Maybe the end of my pointy nail will stab my eye and then it will cry. It's watering a little. Also, when I really let myself go and cry in a scene,
我懂这个套路。然后你调整呼吸，装作：“对，对，对。”抽鼻涕。也许我尖尖的指甲尖会扎到眼睛，然后它就会流泪了。有点湿润了。还有，当我真情流露、在戏里大哭的时候，
it's not attractive. Like I don't have the single tear. It's just a big blubber fest. But I quite like that. I like seeing real crying. Emma Thompson always says, you have to earn your cries. And don't just, I've done shows where, you know, everyone's crying all the time.
一点都不好看。我没有那种单行泪。就是一整个嚎啕大哭。但我挺喜欢那样的。我喜欢看真实的哭泣。艾玛·汤普逊总是说，你的眼泪必须是赢得的。别只是，我拍过一些节目，你知道，里面每个人都在一直哭。
And I'm like, aren't we desensitized to it? And I remember her in Love Actually. I don't know if you've seen it. I love Love Actually. You're speaking Angela's language. That scene with Joni Mitchell, and she opens it up. She thinks it's to be the necklace.
而我就想，难道我们不对这个感到麻木吗？我记得她在《真爱至上》里的表现。不知道你们看过没有。我超爱《真爱至上》。你完全说到了安吉拉的心坎里。她和琼尼·米切尔的那场戏，她打开了那个东西。她以为会是那条项链。
And then she makes the bed and has this resolve that she's going to go and go to the kids' Christmas play. But her dignified crying. Oh, so good. I have to say, just her story with Alan Rickman in that movie alone was worth watching it for. Oh, my goodness. And I was like, yep, was worth watching it for. Oh my goodness. And I was like, yep, you're right, you're crying.
然后她铺好床，下定决心要去参加孩子们的圣诞话剧。但她那种克制的哭泣。哦，太棒了。我必须得说，光是她在电影里和阿伦·里克曼的故事就值回票价了。哦，天哪。当时我就想，没错，值回票价了。哦，天哪。我当时就觉得，没错，你哭了。
Yeah. Oh, yes. Well, listen. Yeah. I want you to come back and I want us to do the Christmas episode. Oh, let's do that. The special. Wouldn't that be so great?
对。哦，是的。好吧，听着。对。我要你回来，我们要把圣诞特辑做完。哦，我们就这么办吧。那个特别篇。那不是很棒吗？
Yes, let's do that. Because now I want to watch it again. We're talking about it and I want to watch it again. And also, by that time, I've got things that I can certainly bring you guys. You can't show it on here. Because I went to look, but I don't have the pilot script. But I do have some scripts still from the show. Wow.
对，就这么办吧。因为现在我又想看了。我们正聊着呢，我又想看了。而且，到那个时候，我肯定能带一些东西给你们。你们不能在这里展示。因为我去找过，我没有试播集的剧本。但我手里确实还有一些节目的剧本。哇。
And some really cool focus. We didn't then have, I didn't, but we didn't have cell phones where you could take a million photos. No, no, we didn't either. So I do have some really cool pictures and stuff. Oh, I would love to see those. Yeah, we'll have to do a Christmas episode. Okay, done. Well, the episode ends with the David Brent talking head
还有一些超酷的照片。那时候我们没有，我没有，但我们没有那种能拍几百万张照片的手机。没有，没有，我们也没有。所以我确实有一些很酷的照片之类的。哦，我很想看看那些。对，我们得做一期圣诞特辑。好吧，一言为定。好了，这一集最后是戴夫·布伦特的独白，
where he's talking about how the most important thing about a company is not, you know, it's not the building, it's not the stock, it's not the stock, it's not the turnover, it's the investment and the people. We did a very similar Michael Scott talking head. It has the same sort of joke where he's like, you know. Gonna be godfather to someone's child. Yeah.
他在里面谈到，一家公司最重要的东西不是，你知道的，不是大楼，不是股票，不是存货，不是营业额，而是对人的投资。我们拍过一段非常相似的迈克尔·斯科特的独白。里面有类似的笑话，比如他会说，你知道的。要当某人孩子的教父。对。
And then fires him. Yes, it didn't work out. It didn't work out. That kind of completes the episode, but before we go, I have to ask, what has it been like for you to be part of this legacy that is the office? People ask us this all the time, but I mean, for you, it's like you started it all.
然后又把人家炒了。是的，结果没成。结果没成。这算是为那一集画上了句号，但在我们结束之前，我必须问问，成为《办公室》这个传奇的一部分，对你来说是怎样的体验？人们总是问我们这个问题，但我是说，对你而言，就像是你开创了这一切。
I think also because we only did the 14 episodes, where you guys, how many episodes did you do? 201. Oh my God. Yeah. Oh my God. That's where I envy you guys. 200 and one. Oh my god. Yeah. That's where I envy you guys. I'd have loved to have done.
我觉得也是因为我们只拍了14集，而你们，你们拍了多少集？201集。天哪。对。天哪。这就是我羡慕你们的地方。201集。天哪。对。这就是我羡慕你们的地方。我本来很想拍……
Just to have, that have been my life for several years. Yeah. So obviously to some degree, because we started much before you, and we only did 40 episodes, to some degree it's a blip in the ocean. But it isn't because of the impact that it had. Yes. I remember the first time we were nominated for awards, it was for the Comedy Awards in England, which are quite big award show and a really fun award show to go to.
只要有那样一段经历，让那成为我好几年的生活。对。所以从某种程度上讲，因为我们比你们开始得早得多，而且我们只拍了40集，从某种程度上讲，这只是大海中的一朵小浪花。但它又不是，因为它的影响力太大了。是的。我记得我们第一次获得奖项提名时，那是英国喜剧奖，这是一个相当盛大的颁奖典礼，也是一个非常有趣的颁奖典礼。
We were nominated for Best Comedy and Ricky for Best Actor. We were like, what? We've been nominated for the Comedy Awards? And I remember chatting with Ricky on the phone that night when we'd heard and he was like, he said, God, I really hope this will become my cult following. Like, and he gave a, I can't remember what comedy he gave an example of. And we're like, would that be amazing if like people actually watched us more and stuff like that. So we just never saw this.
我们获得了最佳喜剧提名，瑞奇获得了最佳演员提名。我们当时就想，什么？我们获得了喜剧奖提名？我记得那天晚上听到消息后跟瑞奇通电话，他说，天哪，我真的很希望这能成为一档拥有狂热粉丝的剧集。比如，他还举了个例子，我记不清他举的是哪个喜剧的例子了。我们当时就在想，如果真的有更多人看我们的节目，那该有多神奇啊。所以我们做梦也没想到会这样。
Yeah. And that lasting-ness of it. Yeah. But yeah, I mean, again, I will know your show more than I will know mine. But that's partly because I don't watch myself hardly ever now. And I've done things that I've never seen. But obviously I've watched all the office. Just don't remember a lot of it. And I wrote a little diary through one of the seasons.
对。而且它具有那种持久性。对。不过，话说回来，我对你们节目的了解肯定比对我自己的节目还要多。但部分原因是我现在几乎从不看自己的表演。我有些拍过的东西甚至从来没看过。但《办公室》的所有剧集我显然都看过了。只是很多细节都不记得了。而且我在其中一季的拍摄过程中写了一小段日记。
At least one of the seasons. You had a journal? A journal. And I wasn't a big journal writer. Lucy, you know I read from my journal that I kept while we were filming the office on here. They love to make fun of me because I, my journal writing, I write like, I don't know,
至少其中一季。你写过日记？一本日志。我以前可不是个爱写日记的人。露西，你知道我在这儿读过我拍《办公室》时写的日记。他们最喜欢拿这个取笑我，因为我，我写日记的方式，我写得就像，我不知道，
what would you say? A fourth grader? Well, we don't know who it's for. It's like you're writing it to your future self so you don't forget things. But with like, it's like you're writing a letter. You'll be like, guess what I did today. Oh, that's great.
你觉得像几年级？四年级学生？好吧，我们也不知道这是写给谁看的。就像是你写给未来的自己，免得忘记一些事情。但感觉就像，就像你在写一封信。你会说，猜猜我今天干了什么。哦，太棒了。
You'll never guess. Rain came by my desk. He farted, it was so stinky. Gross. And then I'll say, and then I'll write something like this, story for later, gotta go. Story for later, like to myself, to yourself. That's what it is.
你永远猜不到。雷来到我的办公桌前。他放了个屁，太臭了。真恶心。然后我会说，接着我会写下这样的话：以后再说的事，得走了。以后再说的事，就像是对自己说的，对自己说。就是这样。
I'm telling myself like diaries. But anyway, you're gonna come back, we're gonna break down the Christmas episode and you're bringing your journal. I like this plan. Okay, I'll do that after we... I remember I did it for a few jobs and I remember thinking it needs to be written so that if God forbid it got into the hands of press or something, it's nothing bad. It's just my day to day or something funny that happened or whatever that is.
我是在自言自语，就像写日记一样。不过不管怎样，你还会回来的，我们要剖析圣诞特辑，而且你要把你的日记带来。我喜欢这个计划。好吧，等我们……我记得我拍好几部作品时都写过日记，我记得当时想过，必须得这样写：万一上帝保佑它落入媒体或其他什么人手里，里面也没有什么不好的内容。这只是我的日常生活，或者发生的一些趣事之类的。
Yeah. I can't wait to hear your journal voice. Thank you. I'm really looking forward to what I'm feeling like. Yeah. I mean, you are an office lady. Mm-hmm. You're the original office lady.
对。我等不及要听听你的日记腔了。谢谢。我很期待自己会有什么感觉。对。我是说，你可是一位“办公室女士”。嗯哼。你才是元老级的“办公室女士”。
You are. I really can't tell you how excited I was to hear from you. And I was like, I wanted to go on this show for ages. Yay! Oh my goodness! Yes. Oh, well thank you so much. I mean, we should tell people how we met.
你真的是。我真的无法形容听到你消息时我有多兴奋。我当时就想，我好想上这个节目好久了。耶！哦，天哪！对。哦，非常感谢。我是说，我们应该告诉大家我们是怎么认识的。
Yes. You were doing a show. A pilot. Yes, here in LA. Yeah. And my manager had another client on the show, and she said, Jenna, you were just cast on the pilot of The Office. Oh, my gosh. And I think it would be really neat for you
对。你当时在拍一个节目。一个试播集。对，就在洛杉矶。对。我的经纪人手下还有另一个演员也在那个节目里，她说：“詹娜，你刚刚被选中出演《办公室》的试播集。”哦，天哪。我想这对你来说会是一件很酷的事：
to come and meet Lucy Davis, who originated the role. Oh, my god. And I did. I came to your set, and I think I watched your taping. Yeah. And that was the Aisha Tyler project, I think. Yes. Produced by Lisa Kudra and Dan Kudjinski.
去见见原版角色的扮演者露西·戴维斯。哦，天哪。然后我就去了。我去了你们的片场，我想我观看了你们的拍摄。对。我想那是艾莎·泰勒的项目。是的。由丽莎·库卓和丹·库金斯基制作。
Yes. Yes, that's right. And I mean, I was so starstruck, I didn't even know what to do. You took a picture with me backstage. She showed us the picture when she came to set. I remember we were all abuzz that she had met you. It was my big brag that I had met you. Oh my gosh. And you were so sweet, and you just were so encouraging.
对。没错，就是那样。我是说，我当时简直惊呆了，都不知道该怎么办才好。你在后台跟我拍了一张合照。她来片场时还给我们看了那张照片。我记得大家都在热议她见到你的事。能见到你可是我当时最大的炫耀资本。哦，天哪。你当时人超级好，而且特别鼓励我。
You said, like, I wish you all the success. I mean, everything you were saying at the beginning of this podcast about like, there's room for all of us. And you can be just as big of a success with your version. And it just, you know, we were so nervous about doing it. And that really helped. I think the cast of our office, we were all rooting for you.
你说，比如，我祝你们一切顺利。我是说，你在播客开头说的那些话，关于“我们所有人都有发展空间”，还有“你的版本也能取得同样巨大的成功”。你知道的，我们当时对出演这部剧感到非常焦虑。那真的很有帮助。我觉得我们办公室的演员阵容，大家都在为你们加油。
We just, we were so, no, God, yeah. You said that and that meant so much. And that gave me so much confidence. So thank you. I am so happy to be back in touch with you. Same. Yeah, me too. It's lovely to meet you, lady. Yes, so lovely to meet you and I can't wait to meet the journal version of you. Oh my God, yes. Lucy, thank you so much for coming by.
我们只是，我们真的，哦天哪，对。你当时那么说，意义太重大了。那给了我极大的自信，所以非常感谢你。我太高兴能跟你重新联系上了。我也是。对，我也是。很高兴认识你，女士。是的，很高兴认识你，我等不及要见见日记里的那个你了。哦天哪，是的。露西，非常感谢你光临。
Yes. What a wonderful day. Thank you. Thank you. Bye, ladies. Bye, original lady. How lovely was that? I mean, I love that I'm back in touch with her. We've been texting up a storm again and it's just, you know, this podcast, we get to reconnect sometimes with people. And it
对。多么美好的一天。谢谢。谢谢。再见，女士们。再见，元老女士。那有多美好啊？我是说，我很高兴能跟她重新取得联系。我们又开始疯狂发短信了，而且你知道的，通过这个播客，我们有时能跟一些人重新建立联系，这
just makes me so grateful. Yeah, I'm so grateful that she came in. She was so excited. She's just such a wonderful person. Like the minute you're in the room with her, I just was like, when are we hanging out again? I know. All right. Well, thank you so much, Lucy, for coming in today. And thank you guys for listening. And we'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer
真的让我心怀感激。对，我非常感激她能来。她当时超级兴奋。她真的是个太棒的人了。只要你跟她处在同一个房间里，我当时就想：我们什么时候能再一起出去玩？我知道。好吧。非常感谢露西今天来到这里。也谢谢大家收听。我们下周见。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Audyssey呈现，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制作人
is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是卡茜·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《鲁珀特树》。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。